foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement Reigns every year with major
upsets and intense battles
year 12 invitees and four qualifiers
face off for the title dozens have tried
but only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test Championship spits
in a row who will be this year's Blitz
King it's time to find out
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are excited to welcome coinbase as the
presenting partner of the speed test
Championship I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me once again is Grandmaster
Benjamin Buck Benjamin we had an
exciting day of Chess yesterday we did
see Yana palmchi take down our generic
icy today Jan has none other than world
number one Magnus Carlsen as his
opponent
hey grower great to be here with you
today it's an exciting day it's a it's
an exciting day because we have Magnus
Carlsen taking on taking on a Jana
ponyachi and Robert this is a rematch of
the 2021 World Chess Championship
it is indeed a rematch of that world
championship in 2021 and Magnus Carlson
he took that title in fewer games than
were required of the match so Magnus you
see the final moves of that championship
and finally they shake hands Magnus
retains the title but Benjamin I think
Yan wants a different outcome today
yeah I know for sure today is going to
be different it was a classical World
Chess Championship match today is going
to be fast and furious as they take each
other on in the speed Chess Championship
it's a different version of himself
having what two candidates tournaments
you know his name is up there with the
best in the world but unfortunately for
him he plays the absolute best in the
world the number one player for over a
decade in Magnus Carlson so let's dive
in to the bracket to see how the players
were able to make their way to the
quarterfinals and bedroom we already
know two of our semi-finalists akara
Nakamura beat so I better carwana
yesterday and Wesley show took down
farrugia a couple days ago so Magnus
Carlson Beyond the Palm Street the
winner of this upcoming match will face
Wesley in the semis
yeah now this is going to be a very
exciting Metro so yeah the winner will
face Wesley and they would pave the way
to a potential final again and we see
that upper bracket Hikaru he's marching
on to the final as well
hey card Nakamura Magnus Carlson
maintains of mate stays I should say of
the speed Chess Championship and for
Magnus it was business as usual in The
Opening match against vidit Gujarati
because Magnus he ended up with a nine
point victory over the Indian Super
Grand Master so Benjamin I think that
Magnus though he was hard on himself in
the post-match interview he took care of
it when he needed to
yeah it was just a regular day of the
opposite team for Magnus Village gave
him a very good match but overall Magnus
won quite convincingly we see that
especially the biggest difference was in
the bull portion and yeah we saw we saw
Young's match John Wall have to really
play at his A-game to give her Magnus a
tough match here
and Magnus Carlsen
92.7 average accuracy in the opening
round six brilliances compared to none
for his opponent he had the highest
average accuracy in the first round so
Magnus doing Magnus things and on the
other side of this match will be yawned
upon machine Benjamin his match against
Arjun that was very different that was a
nail biter
you know that one was very very up and
down John was leading for the most part
at some point he was even down in the
match but he won't finally buy a one
point difference Robert we see that he
took the lead in the five plus one
origin at some point was leading by two
points but John's nurse uh were the
strongest in the final couple of games
he took three and a half out of the
Final Four Points to steal Victory from
the jaws of defeat janapam she moved on
but if we look at this graphic here the
average accuracy lower than Magnus is
and also nine blunders Benjamin I don't
think Jan can afford that many against
Magnus Carlson
no for sure not against Arjun he lost
one game by disconnect also he lost many
he lost a few games right out of the
opening and against Magnus he has to
take every single opportunity that will
be presented to him and he's gonna try
to avoid losing games unnecessarily and
the good thing though for Yan is that if
he can get rid of those blunders there
is a lot of room for improvement
that's true because if he doesn't lose
in say 13 moves as he did against oxygen
Yesterday by slipping in the opening his
chances will be better and Jan was in a
good mood at least a jovial mood after
the match because he took to Twitter or
should we call it X these days he
tweeted just a yawn so how appropriate
for his name but he is trying to take
that Michael Jordan route he took it
personally that he was not initially
invited to the SEC
yep but today he might be playing the
Michael Jordan off chess we know how
good Magnus Crossing is it was an
absolute Thriller that he uh beat Arjuna
Air Guys yesterday but he's gonna play
much better today if he wants to have a
real chance of beating Magnus
it's true because Magnus as we keep
talking about he is the final boss often
in the Chess World Hikaru Nakamura he is
a claim to that in the SEC as well but
let's look at the tail of the tape
because it's important to dive into the
numbers and we are thrilled to have
Deloitte a leader in their field as the
official Data Insights partner for the
speed Chess Championship their
dedication to Excellence aligns
perfectly with the chess.com mission to
grow the game at sport of Chess let's
dive in to our Deloitte game analytics
and Benjamin here we see it Magnus much
higher rated in Blitz chess but they've
never actually played on chess.com how
crazy is that
yeah it's quite remarkable that they
never played on Chelsea come I think
it's because young wasn't active for a
while Magnus also was not active but
Robert look at the numbers they're
Jessica Blitz rating is almost is more
than 200 points apart that is a very big
very big margin
it really is and it cannot be overstated
because Magnus he's a blitz beast and
Jana Pomchi he's been improving
unfortunately Benjamin sorry to bring
this up again we talked about his title
Tuesday win earlier in the week where
you face him in the last round but it
goes to show that Jan maybe he's on the
upswing
yeah I know for sure he's been working
on his game he also used to be up to 30
to 100 so he he's uh he's definitely
capable of bringing his his A-game he
has a high ceiling so to speak but he
really has to play at his A-game today
and he also has to hope that Magnus will
play a little bit below his A-game
because it magnus's a game he has a game
win rate 56 that's absolutely nuts he's
the only player above 50 that means each
and every game he plays he's 56 likely
to win it in the SEC so Jan needs to
slow that down and as you said young
ceiling is very high but sometimes his
floor is a bit low as we saw him losing
13 moves yesterday he needs to avoid
those types of blunders
yeah I know for sure he has to play well
from start to finish I wonder what kind
of preparation he is done going into
this match I also wonder how Magnus
approaches us we match we've seen that
Hikaru has been playing bingo pretty
much playing one and three playing one
H3 things of that nature I I wonder if
Magnus is going to take the opening a
little bit more seriously
and well Magnus Carlson we know he's the
heavy favorite let's jump into the
smarter chess predictions I typically
you know have some beef with those
predictions but I think this one won't
be too much of a surprise Magnus Carlson
predicted to win by a final score of 18
to 10. 85 win probability Benjamin does
that meet your expectations
yeah no I think Magnus is a pretty hefty
favorite to win this home we see that
this biggest actual probably being the
bullet portion Jan he uh while he was
behind in the ball Porsche but
eventually he won the match yesterday
against Arjun there but
um yeah we saw also the Magnus won by a
big margin and bullet bullets very much
come down to your intuition and we know
that magnus's intuition maybe it's on
par with with hikar but other than that
he's just he's often destroying people
there
yes not many can match up with Magnus
Carlsen who's a two-time winner of the
speed Chess Championship chat get
involved let us know your predictions
will it be the man on the screen in
front of you Magnus Carlson winning this
match or do you think Jan the pump
should get revenge for the 2021 world
champion John he's looking refreshed I
mean he's looking like a man who's ready
to take on the number one player in the
world but he needs to improve yesterday
was a win it was a close one but it's
not going to be good enough to take down
Magnus
yeah no for sure yeah again he has to
play better than yesterday yesterday I
was a little bit sloppy at times like we
said you know making or losing some
games right out of the opening you
cannot afford that at all also he let
some opportunities slip so again if he
brings his A-game I think we are in for
a very exciting match the question is if
he can
that's the question that only he can
answer and the games are going to start
in any second now we see Magnus is
adjusting his camera young he looks
focused Benjamin I'm excited for this
one
yeah and I'm excited for sure it's uh
again the rematch of the 2021 World
shows Championship so this one might
also be a little bit personal for both
of the players also again these players
are from the same generation they're
both born in 1990 as we speak by the way
we're off and again like they've played
in World youth Under 12 championships
they go way way back and John actually
had the lead in their head to head
history until that world championship
match when it was a one-sided victory
for Magnus we have a Petrov and
for this match I'm wondering is yon
gonna try to be more solid or is he
going to bring his chaotic brand of
Chess which has scored him some fine
victories in his career but also can
backfire if you play a little too
loosey-goosey
yeah I think he's gonna try to stick to
a style try to play aggressively
especially with the white piece against
Magnus he wasn't quite able to do so in
the match but that is also very
impressive from magnus's uh part that he
doesn't let John into his A-game so to
speak and he turned the game into a more
grindy slow positions but let's see what
do we have here Robert we had it started
out out as a petrol but it turned into a
bit of a French exchange pretty boring
so far but we know how Magnus can work
as magic here we see Magnus he's eating
his lunch so he's just taking it step by
step but I agree with you the reason why
we call this position a bit boring so to
speak is there's no Pawn tension only
one Pawn has been traded per side we
haven't seen anything of note in a
symmetrical structure so let's see how
this one develops but I wonder Benjamin
do you think it's match strategy for
Magnus not just to get his meal in at
the start but to sort of see what Jan
wants in the opening stages
yeah and I think it definitely makes
sense to see Yan has been singing to his
guns he played the pattern of Defense he
played that in their world championship
match as well I'm not too impressed so
far with magnus's opening choice I think
John is doing fairly well I mean Magnus
has these slightly more active pieces
however this dynasty three can sometimes
be slightly misplaced as it's currently
restricted by the policy six Queen E2 I
like the move by Magnus as H6 would
invite the sacrifice over here another
favorite a nice move by yawn and look at
the clock for but John does this very
well he's already up on the up on time
and perhaps Magnus might be struggling a
little bit with this uh because normally
he's the one putting pressure and Jan
often is the one putting pressure on him
and look at this position The Rook gets
to the open file black can develop that
light Square Bishop to maybe E6 but it
does feel a little bit like Black's
pieces are fighting for the same squares
like both the Knight and the bishop want
to go to E6 that's a good Square for
them both so white so far the pieces
feel a little bit more fluid there's a
more natural set of squares for them but
ultimately yeah I'm not super impressed
with what Magnus has done and yet he
wins games just like this that seem
unwinnable that seem like nothing he'll
probably Knight E5 here and then it
starts to seem like he's going to go for
a bit of initiative
yeah 95 seems like a nice move putting
the knight in the middle I wonder if
young can take on D4 but that does look
fairly risky in there we've seen with 95
now perhaps after Knight takes D4 maybe
Magnus can take enough six you're gonna
have to capture the G pawn and at the
very least there's something like Queen
H6 you can also take a D7 and take an H7
so I suppose staying on D4 is too risky
for Yana maybe he has to play something
more solid like Bishop D7 because for
them oh and wow there we go wrong
but we were saying at the start of the
show you can't afford blunders or sort
of crazy chess if it's not objectively
strong against Magnus Carlson that
earned a question mark and I think it's
simple Bishop takes 99 F6 as you
mentioned you have to take with the pawn
on F6 and then even just take on D7
Black's Pawn structure is going to be
worse I love what Magnus has been able
to achieve from what looked like a
nothing opening
yeah so let's see what Magnus has to do
everything Bishop take the six is
certainly the start if you take it to
Queen you leave the bishop on D7 hanging
so perhaps you're gonna have to
recapture with the pawn now you can take
on D7 take on H7 afterwards and then
take on D4 and perhaps that is the
position and Jana's going for and he
might feel like after someone like Queen
of five he's not doing too bad but I do
wonder if Magnus can take and go Queen
H6 because how exactly do you stop the
threat of checkmate
maybe black would have to play Move Like
Bishop F or Knight F5 or something like
that but yeah you're hanging on barely
at that stage so I think Magnus is he's
working out what we're talking about
right here you need to be precise you
need to come up with the correct move
order because if you get a little bit
lazy say with like Knight takes D7 now
Queen takes D7 maybe at some point black
will have a different move order that
helps his chances
yeah no for sure so yeah it looks
extremely risky Magnus investing some
time but I'm sure he's going to go down
this line with takes F6 Pawn takes
what oh he takes on base he takes on H7
wow Robert I guess in case it takes I
won't stick enough seven or four of the
queen and the bishop oh that's actually
pretty nice I wasn't even looking in
that direction and in that situation the
queen and Bishop are forked and the
Knight on D4 is still loose so maybe
black has to throw in like a knight F3
check at some point just to shatter
white spawn structure but this does look
like a situation where Magnus has the
upper hand not uh yawn he didn't expect
that he reacted to Knight takes up
something oh didn't see that one coming
yeah no that's um yeah a little bit
sloppy by Young I think Knight takes D4
was a little bit rushed so let's see
what he's going to do here Knight F3 is
certainly a possibility of white has to
take and then perhaps Queen C7
Magnus has to be doing well there I mean
maybe it feels like he's more likely to
take advantage of the open G file young
can of course also move the queen right
away but after Queen takes D4 white is
an extra pawn and their King is safer
this looks really bad for black and you
could take on F6 at some moment for
white if you want to shatter the king
said even more because I don't think
black can ever afford to take that
Bishop with the queen swooping into H6
so Benjamin this is looking very
problematic for Yan and it went from a
completely even looking position and
then Magnus makes one forward jump with
his Knight earlier in the game and Jan
did not react in the best way
yeah we've been talking about this
before to match Jan again like he if he
wants to give himself a good chance he
has to try to avoid losing games like
this he has to try to hang in there
usually he plays faster than Magnus so
perhaps he can get Magnus in the time
pressure but if he blunders early on
then you're just going to get a lot of
points to Magnus and that's going to
make it very tough
and when have we ever heard of Magnus
relinquishing a lead the matches that
he's lost that I can think of including
last year's speed Chess Championship to
Hikaru uh the bullet Chess Championship
match against both alireza and Hikaru it
he was losing out of the gates and then
he was trying to come back so for
madness winning game one would be huge
and for Jan if anyone can win a game on
demand I I do trust Jan he is so
creative but it's just not what you want
in a match against Magnus Carlson
know for sure because Magnus he could
also be extremely solid and almost
impossible to beat If he if he wants to
and yeah like I said I think you have
the best chance against Magnus if you
win early on hang on to that lead that
might also make him a little bit nervous
maybe he's gonna Rush a little bit to
try to come back and finally we see Jan
settling on the Move Queen to C7 so now
let's see what Magnus is going to do I
guess he should take on D4 to take the
knight in case of Knight takes D6
perhaps then yawn can throw in that move
Knight F3 check and force you to double
your pawns another three check I think
was not really a possibility before
because white also has this option to go
over 606 combined with Queen a check so
I think right now Magnus is either going
to take this Knight or take the Knight
on D4
it's a good call and the problem from
Magnus is he can only take one piece at
a time and if you take the knight in F6
black for sure will not take back with
the g-pawn I think that Knight on D4
will slide back to F5 and you're just
trying to keep your king as safe as
possible so maybe white will remain up a
pawn but it's pawns on separate sides of
the board black has an extra Pawn to the
D file white has two extra pawns on the
king side and that creates a dynamic
imbalance that should help in Black's
chances to hold if white is not able to
crash through against that black king
yeah we see main is falling quite far
behind on the clock here he's dropping
below a minute
I think he he's still in very good shape
here
he's got a dominant position but you got
to be careful especially against John
who's so extremely pressure who is so
extremely tricky when you're in
temperature because 96 wait but Robert
that was the mistake we were talking
about I think now Jana is doing quite
fine actually I'm not sure why Magnus
went for this because look at these
Pawns in the king side now you have the
split f-pawns and the loose h-pawn
that's under attack he goes in with his
Queen but suddenly look at the eval bar
say black is actually the side for
Choice Knight E4 forcing those Queens
off and how could black be worse in this
end game double exclamed deserved from
yawn because that way his King is safe
Benjamin this is starting to turn around
yeah great move by Young he's offering
the trade of Queens I don't think
there's a good way for menus to uh to
get out of it and he does go for the
Queen the opponent H3 is hanging out
these pawns are weak Bishop F5 is an
option or Knight C4 I think this one and
also Robert after Knight C4 you turn to
go Knight D2 and look at the clock
magnets down to 18 seconds
and that's a very good response of King
the G2 because the Knight could take B2
but I've worked with a slit to B1 to win
the B7 pawn and get some activity so
very good find from Magnus if I'm
looking at the clock he's down to 10
seconds bedroom he's Gotta Move
E2 all right so Jan can just take the
spawn over here now and get a pretty
significant Advantage I guess minus is
playing good 94. I don't know he's in
real trouble here Robert perhaps John
can sort of hot in this match
it didn't look like that at first but if
he grabbed these Queen side pods I would
take on C2 as you said now black has his
unopposed d-pawn passer White's pawns
they're gross double F and isolated H
they can't create a pass Pawn very
easily this looks like Jan napomzy's
game he needs a pressure magnets on the
clock
yeah and that's what he's doing he takes
on the he takes on C2 goes Bishop D3 and
now he can take another Pawn he doesn't
do so now Magnus goes B3 the position
might be manageable here because where
do you actually go with the Knight
this is a mistake from Yanni on it said
he's backtracking but look at Magnus
pushing for an A5 father A6 was a threat
that's why black played A5 but that's a
long-term weakness if that Bishop slides
to C7 at the right moment A5 could be a
Target
but look at the clock man that's not a
four seconds John has to be doing well
here but let's see if he can create some
problems for Magnus
I I think Magnus objectively he should
be doing fine like it's obviously color
Bishops these spawns are blocked over
here on the queen side it's difficult to
make use of them but the clock the
he's barely getting his moves off I mean
he's 2.9 seconds after that move you
gained one second of increment everybody
I think Bishop F4 was a good choice that
Bishop go to E3 or to G5 it will block
the black Rooks and now Magnus might
play B4 himself and just start trading
on Pawns
yeah so let's see how Jana's gonna try
to do this Rook G6 check I guess we met
with Bishop to G5 he goes work to C8
perhaps aiming to set a spawn some
motion but for now you can as well hang
the pawn on D5 and with the move Bishop
the G5 Magnus is actually creating that
threat oh
yes because it wasn't available to move
ago because Rook G6 would have been
checked there's no check against the
white King The Rook I'd see it is loose
now Magnus he can go from a position
where he was worse to potentially one
where he could try to outplay Yan
although with Bishops of opposite color
this realistically should just be it's
something but H5 H5 was a great move
there H5 again and said oh because you
cannot take okay no yeah he's he's
setting up a tribe now HR is a big
threat
right so King Aid therefore by John okay
so now we have H5 John just takes it
okay King G3 this game probably a job
that can still go either way with both
players getting a long time and here
comes the F Pawn I said they weren't
good but upon f u four takes G5
what what a runner and Rook takes a five
is just a game because you can wow and
Jana ponyachi takes the first game
Robert
it looked like Madness was well on his
way to a first game victory at least
right after that Knight E5 and the
tactics happened but yonda Palm she he's
showing that he could be resilient he
can fight back I cannot believe he won
that game I mean it looked like there
was no chance and there was a one move
blunder because of time trouble and Jan
he capitalizes
that was absolutely incredible yeah he
almost was doing well before when he
took Upon A C2 he could have also taken
upon B2 but after that Magnus seemed to
be out of the woods he had that
opportunity to go H5 on a couple of
occasions he missed it and then it
seemed to be just headed for a job but
then he made a terrible blunder at a
five Robert
oh my goodness what a howler and I want
to get the chat involved once again do
you change your mind a lot of you had
Magnus winning do you still think that's
gonna be it was just one game I know but
Jana Pomchi he's showing some good form
in the first game and here in the second
it looks like he's breaking open the
queen side Benjamin it looks like Aurora
Lopez but it started as a Sicilian
exactly yeah it started off as a Russell
limo and black played this line with E5
and Bishop to D6 very creative I think
he core has also played this a couple of
times at some point white is going to go
D4 or D3 and we will see a trade here
black will have this backwards Palm on
D7 or on D6 reminiscent of a sashnikov
but in return black has got a lot of uh
piece activity
yeah look like a Spanish a smashnikov
that backwards d-pawn as you're pointing
out it could be a problem but look at
this Pawn on B5 it's either a bad Pawn
because white can Target it and look at
Jan not sure how to take on D3 he takes
to the queen and that Bishop on D6 is
under threat so I think it gives white
just another move to develop because you
have to take care of the bishop Bishop
G5 next potentially for white or Rook to
D1 and I have to say I do like the look
of this position for Yonder palmishi
yeah it's a typical yellow Polynesian
position he's got a slight initiative
easy piece play and Magnus has a couple
of weaknesses so I think Jan cannot be
unhappy At All by what he's got here out
of the opening but Robert we talked
about the match beforehand this is
exactly what John needs he needs a good
start and uh yeah this could potentially
become quite an exciting match
for sure this move B4 it doesn't
threaten anything I think that young can
just develop Knight to D2 then bring
that Knight to C4 and just increase the
potential of your pieces that Rook on A1
is maybe the best piece on the board
because at some point black would love
to play Bishop A6 that's not gonna
happen and that backwards d-pawn remains
an issue
yeah for sure young can I always go
Knight C4 on kids with D6 putting
pressure on the pawn like you said move
around to D1 and he's just got the
easier piece play he's got this open A4
for his rook in case Magnus Moose's
Bishop let's say the E6 there's always
going to be an annoying Rook A6 move so
that is why we see that magnus's
possible thing again I think John he's
doing pretty well here so far
and let's be honest Benjamin did you
expect at all that Jan would take a game
like that in the first one where it
seemed like a very typical Magnus type
of position better could you have
expected John to take that first game
and then now have a slightly better
position in the game too
I did not expect it I did not expect it
but Magnus has to be a little bit
careful he's going down on the clock
again we saw in game one he had a
dominant position but with only seconds
on the clock really anything can happen
a one second increment really is not a
whole lot and everyone makes big
mistakes and it's part of Jan's overall
match strategy we saw that yesterday he
likes to be faster than his opponent and
speaking of faster this Knight goes to
C4 and look at how quickly it will land
on E3 and F5 and D5 and watch out
because if you get Knight D5 that Knight
F6 is pinned and if you do take what say
a bishop on D5 if your e takes D5 there
are checkmating ideas across the
diagonal
exactly yeah y'all would love to open up
this thing oh G5 wow is he gone I think
she fights second yeah look at the time
look at Black's King Benjamin come on
would you be able to resist
I mean perhaps but I don't think John
will be able to I think he's gonna go
for it so let's see so it takes takes
Queen E6 what exactly is the follow-up
Robert
I haven't figured that out but F4 is
typically a good move to play when your
opponent's king is open and you're
trying to open not just the f file but
also the diagonal from B1 to H7 for
checkmating ideas it looks scary and Jan
probably wants to make sure he at least
has a bailout for everyone who's
watching that's important maybe he sees
a variation where he can at least Force
the draw he probably didn't so he goes
Bishop to G3 and as you see in x marks
the spot but it also marks the Miss
Knight takes G5 was better
yeah Bishop G3 he still keeps an
initiative he has pressure on the E5
Pawn also in case Magnus was the sexiest
pressure there so perhaps he feels like
he has an advantage here as well and so
it wasn't necessary to go for it but
Robert that might have been a missed
opportunity I like what you suggested
there with taking on G5 followed by F4
it looks like it just blasts open the
black king side but perhaps John he you
know he trusts himself of course he's a
very intuitive player but he knows that
sometimes he has gone a little bit too
far and so I think your point is well
taken Benjamin his position is still
good in fact the eval bar is the same
now as if Knight takes G5 so why did he
have to sacrifice material he says let
me just play this very good looking
position and we keep talking to this Jan
you know who beats Yan the most is
himself so he does not want to do that
in this match
and 93 here in the meantime nice move
but young 98 by Magnus all right so
let's see what John's gonna do here I
mean he can move around to D1 Rook a
seven is a possibility Knight d8 looks a
little bit odd to me as I don't see
where the Knight is headed they cannot
go to e6's you allow the Knight to jump
to F5 we see just Rook if you won by by
yawn and again this is where he's good
at he's got a lead on the clock he's got
that initiative and Magnus is struggling
so far
and I'm trying to figure out why it
could oh my goodness there are some
tactics I think with like a knight D4
and a knight D5 if black is not careful
that's what rookie one might have set up
here because there's gonna be a
Checkmate on the H7 Square this is
getting very difficult for madness and
he plays Bishop B6 so I'm wondering is
ah The Bishop's defended on B6 now that
might be a huge difference
still wait 94 yeah in case you take
there might be moose like 95 combined
with a timely E5 push and white always
has the check being Eddie here on H7 so
I think after 94 black might as think of
the bishop to stop by it from putting a
knight on F5 but that looks terrible so
he goes Rook to B1 how can you blame him
from changing his Rook to pin this
bishop on B6 and that's why Magnus
defensive but Knight can we get an
analysis for it I think Knight D4 is
super instructive giving up a minor
piece in the center to try to Checkmate
the enemy King
right because if you take it then you go
Knight D5 attacking the queen and the
Knight if you think of the Knight
White's gonna recapture the queen is
under attack and you threaten Checkmate
over here so white wins and in case you
play Queen E6 then well you can take the
bishop but there's also all these E5
idiots with that you deliver to deliver
Checkmate over here so let's say if Yelm
is going to go for it he's he's just
paused and usually when Jung pauses he
comes up with something interesting he's
played H4 though
oh and we see it as the game continues
uh there are trades now and H4 earned a
question mark because it wasn't uh as
quick as he needed to be and Bishop
takes E3 earns an exclamation point now
Benjamin as we see these moves it looks
like white still has potential to attack
but that Knight on E6 is such a strong
piece there's no longer Knight F5 and
that means that black is probably out of
the woods
exactly then they jump into F5 really
was the sting in uh in Black's position
Magnus took that out and now you cannot
take the pawn on G5 because if you take
black has Knight to G4 attacking the
queen and opening up this attack on the
Knight end so you lose a piece so here
Magnus is doing absolutely fine and now
the time is evened out so let's see how
Jan will handle this situation
I think that not only this bank is doing
fine you see the evil barsing about
zeros I kind of like Black's position
like right now Knight H5 maybe we'll get
a knight F4 that's exactly what's
happening and G4 comes to mind at the
right moment if you want to go all into
the attack but I just feel like Black's
pieces are Freer and that C3 Pawn that's
the worst single Pawn on the board
yeah the policy three is quite weak the
pawn on D6 is still weak as well but
after Rook D1 you can just defend him
with Rook to d8 also I think if anything
Magnus is more likely to take advantage
of the open H Charlie he can go King G7
followed by Rook date Knight C5 a nice
move by Magnus attack on e4 so Jan just
has to slide back in the here we go
Robert King G7
you're on point right now oh Rook to D1
is there a G4 coming I'd first defend
the D6 Pawn that looks too weak so it
goes Rook d8 G4 can happen next Rook h a
queen H4 that will happen and it will
hurt and also Bishop A6 Knight E2 check
let's not forget about that
yeah this looks unpleasant for you and
he goes back to G3 one thing he has to
one thing Magnus has to be careful of is
not a good G4 too quickly as there might
be some Knight xc5 tactics uh we see
Queen E3 all right this looks very tough
to be honest I don't see what he's gonna
do and Magnus has this very easy plan
queen of six Queenie chicks and
Checkmate along the H final
so what is he gonna do after Queen F6
the queen H6 is next he might have to
after that put a knight on H2 and pray
that his Bishop on G3 holds everything
together it looks bad but I don't see
the actual breakthrough
yeah I know for sure but Magnus has
turned this one completely around he
seems to be under a lot of pressure he's
got to speed up here though he's
dropping down to 40 seconds he takes an
F3 interesting decision I guess now he
wants to go Queen E6 move the screen
over to the HL as now there's no longer
net H2 and the Queen on E6 is better
than the queen and F6 if King F1 I
refers on this check made it one but
just in general there's a queen C4 type
of ideas so the point is the queen is
staring in both directions and that's
why it's probably a better Square than
F6
obviously young rookie doing perhaps
clearing the way a little bit for his
King so let's see who maintenance is
going to do so in case of Queen H6 do we
have Queen G4 he starts with a rook to
H6 wow what is the idea behind this one
I think he's just defending the D6 pod
so his Queen can go to C4 A2 he's gonna
start going after the White Queen side
Queen B3 is an option here the C3 Pawn
is loose or he'll Focus all his
attention on the king side but I don't
know how to make a Checkmate happen
yeah Queen B3 good move putting
suppression on policy three all right so
let's see what what John is going to do
here it looks it looks extremely tough I
don't see an activity here for him
anymore he goes with F1 84. 964.
minus could just take this pawn and he
goes for it
that Queen is overloaded and that's what
the rook's doing on H6 and queen G4 is
always Rook G6 to block the chat oh
Robert look at this instead of Knight F6
he had Queen xd1 Rook h12 leading to
winning end game let's bring up announce
this morning if we can maybe let's wait
actually till the game ends and then
we'll pull up one after but that was
such a good find by you this still looks
good for Magnus if he gets his Queen to
h8 that's what he's aiming for
but look at how creative Jonas with his
defense he's maneuver this Bishop from
F1 to D3 to 5 to H3 to block the H1 and
now to Pawn on D6 Magnus only has two
seconds so I take take and take any five
he just dropped his Central Pawn that is
unacceptable because now your winning
chances are not very high and this
position do you still think Magnus is
trying to win it
I think so but I don't think he should I
mean Rook F5 just just looks like a draw
yeah Rook see one check he is shooting
Knight takes F2 there's no Checkmate
because Rook takes F4 gets rid of the
mating Pawn
what a what a throw by Magnus now the
game antenna draw so let's pull that up
real quick Robert after Bishop to D3
Manish could have taken on D1 play Rook
H1 and take on F2 and at the end of it
oh and at the end I don't know at least
two or is it even three Pawns yeah I
think uh we got the majority of it that
was such a beautiful tactic uh we've
seen that by some of the best players in
the world but so easy to miss because
you have to give your queen and realize
you can sacrifice your rook in the
corner temporarily being down a full
Queen and look at this speaking of no
Queens on the board Queen E2 Queen E7
what are we watching here Benjamin
we're watching the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase but
this game isn't the most exciting so far
uh yeah pretty boring isn't this
something that Magnus played in the
world championship match when he wanted
to make a draw anyway we've seen ipd7
but this check to be fair though Robert
it looks unpleasant for black why does
very easy piece play the king of f8 is
kind of stuck you can go G6 for the
moment as there's Bishop Hicks check
again we see the 95 move and it's not as
easy for Yan to bring his pieces into
the game
I'm with you I mean these type of dry
openings they're highly criticized but
it does give Madness I think the edge
because Jan prefers a more open board he
is a tactician he likes to play quickly
but in a position like this how can you
play quickly do you play F6 right now uh
do you play on The Queen side you can't
trade on E5 that much is clear and he
does go F6 but it's not easy to make
choices like this as they create
weaknesses E6 Square the F5 Square not
an easy position
the king of seven I think he's done a
good job crawling out of his passive
position now perhaps he can move this
bishop or move the Knight he still has
to bring the light Square Bishop into
the game so let's see how he will try to
do so Magnus has more space we know how
he can really be uh a boa constrictor
right he can slowly but surely surround
His position tighten the screws we see
G5 I think a nice move by Young grabbing
some space on a king side mainness could
take but that's going to open up the age
of freon and this should be quite five
for black but I think G5 was a critical
move it opened up some squares for his
pieces because Bishop F4 is going to
happen regardless and the instead of
this there could have been a white Pawn
on F5 and that would have just
restricted Black's pieces so Knight F5
Retreat of course that's a good move
defending the G6 Pawn opening the light
Square Bishop Yan he looked like he had
a bit of a tough one and yet he is able
to neutralize most of White's advantage
yeah exactly not a five nights if he
gets the opportunity I think he would
love to go G5 kick the Knight away then
develop his bishop and go rookie eight
and then the position should be quite
even as the as the pawn structure is
symmetrical so let's see what Magnus has
to do I think he has a couple of moves
to try to develop an initiative now G5
is not possible as it allows Knight
takes G5 followed by Knight takes D5
with a discovery on the king in the
night so what do you do maybe King G7
Robert but then there's rook ae1 and you
turn to side into E7
moves like Rook F1 are so nice because
they just create these problems for your
opponent now Rook a to E1 maybe black
has a playground Knight C to E6 remember
everyone the Knight on f8 came there not
just to open up the light Square Bishop
but to protect the G6 Pawn so Rook a to
E1 Knight to E6 from the C7 Square I
feel like black is doing a good job and
there's a few moves away from being
completely stable Bishop D7 Rook E8
after that and finally black is
coordinated
right so we'll try it we'll see how
Magnus will try to build on this
initiative 96 nice move all right it's
not easy at all yeah in case it takes
you can just recapture
so I don't see it Robert let's see how
Magnus will will try to work his magic
here he's again down on the clock yarn
is always putting that pressure
it's not easy playing you on the palm
machine he's such a Speed Demon and here
I think strategically white doesn't
really want to trade on E6 and that's
why Knight D2 is like if you take an F4
that's a blunder because Rook E7 check
will happen first even if Knight takes
D4 have that pawn we already saw yon
gobble opponent of D4 in the first game
it wasn't working out well for him he's
certainly not going to take it here
yeah I don't think so why not just a
move like Bishop to D7 develop the
bishop follow Over The Rook that he ate
and I think black is doing absolutely
fine and there we go Bishop D7 so I
don't know manga seemed to be having a
slight initiative but John has done a
great job at neutralizing it
yarn has been very steady today and he
with a one point lead right now the onus
is on Magnus Carlsen to strike back at
some moment but Jan is looking relaxed I
saw the feature chat saying that but
it's true he's leaning back in his
chairs doing the rock away and he's also
developing his pieces and just bringing
his Rook to the center
yeah for sure I mean I guess John also
knows that he doesn't have a whole lot
to lose against Magnus Magnus of course
is the Hefty favorite so you know if he
wins that'd be uh that'd be fantastic if
he loses you know it's uh it happens you
know you just uh you just move on so I
guess there's not a whole lot of
pressure on him he knows what it takes
to beat bangness he's beat the Magnus if
I believe uh like four times in
classical chess so he knows what he has
to do
that's correct and even though the world
championship didn't go his way I think
that it was great preparation for him it
was a great experience and a second
world championship didn't go his way but
it's clear that he's uh improving in
many different areas of the game and one
of them is being increasingly solid
playing the opening like the Petrov and
he maintains in this one in equal
position and I don't see much of
anything here Benjamin young he may have
bet in the first game but he's showing
that he is not going to break
bring the organ to the game now Magnus
finally defends Upon Us 1964 was
threatened so let's see what John is
going to do here maybe like Knight G5
after the trade of Rooks trade
everything off and black should be doing
absolutely fine in that end game that
being said of all the Rooks come off why
can't perhaps hope for a very very small
Edge as you will have the potential
outside passer you also have your pawns
on darshwares and we have light Square
Bishops on the board
very very instructive points there
everyone please take note of what
Benjamin just said that because white
can create an outside pass Pawn certain
end games will be very nice especially
King and pawn end games because black
will be distracted towards the flank and
then white could operate more in the
center and the light Square Bishops
clearly favor white because of those
light Square pawns which means one the
white can attack Black's pawns and two
blacks Bishop is restricted so Magnus
might be counting on that but I also
wouldn't be surprised if one of them
offers a draw in the next couple moves
as all the Rooks come off the board it
would take a big mistake for someone to
lose this game
yes we'll see an idea at rookie 8 okay
so here man is going to trade go King
and there we have the movie H4 Robert he
wants to create that outside pass I
guess now you go G3 Jan isn't too eager
to trade like you said that outside
passer will give white some very small
chances but never seven on the board a
very solid move I think he's headed to
D6 followed by Bishop G6 and so it's an
icon potentially go to Five this should
be a comfortable hold for Yana I think
it should be but we've said that so many
times when Magnus Carlson is playing
someone should make a draw Leslie John
just offered a draw and Magnus declined
it by playing take on G5 so a draw was
offered Magnus not interested and this
still looks very level
but your G6 a nice move here by Young
the pollen G5 was under attack but for
the moment you cannot take it as your
Bishop D3 is hanging and if you trade on
G6 first well then the King on G6
defends the pawn so nice move it puts
the bishop on a more active diagonal we
see the trade here Robert I think this
one is gonna end in a drop pretty soon
this the position is completely
symmetrical there's nothing to attack
right the knight in D6 protects the B7
Pawn if the Knight comes to C4 for black
well you could play B3 and the king is
marching toward the center let me ask
you Benjamin did Magnus decline because
he might want the quicker type controls
where he feels like he's even more of a
favorite do you think he's sort of
wasting some match clock even in just
the first few games
yeah I don't know it's a good it's a
good question on the other hand though
he is behind so he should won more games
than a match I would think from Jan's
perspective
a draw like milking out the clock here
is not a bad idea again you you get uh
less games in the match so I I think
Magnus perhaps should resign himself to
a draw here sooner rather than later
there's just nothing to be done right
the Knight on E5 protects G4 the night
that was on e4 protected G5 there's
nothing to go after here I think both
players they know it's a draw and yet
Magnus he always finds some chances look
at this C5 does he want King D3 King C3
B4 it's not gonna happen right there's
no way and he had to move his Knight
back because Knight takes C5 was a
threat there so
is Magnus really playing for a win here
or is he just shuffling about
yeah I don't know what to make of this
move Knights he threw I don't know why
Yelm didn't just go back to F6 it looks
very natural now Magnus can play the
move Knight F2 cutting off the return to
the force car Jan however can go 92 to
B4 so he's still doing absolutely fine
but I don't know like the thing with
Magnus is that the evil bar is always in
the middle but at some point it's slowly
but surely is going to creep up
that's because the Evo board doesn't
take into context how difficult it feels
to play a position a big issue right now
for Magnus is he would love to attack
the A5 Pawn but his Knight doesn't have
a single Square in the board where it
can attack it from oh it's nice Robert I
think C5 oh
did they what was their Knight takes no
no it was not even Knight takes c66
there so that was amazing C5 was a big
opportunity for you in case you take you
win the knight at Knight 66 there's a
there's 94.
so somehow the evil Bar says that's not
even that impressive regardless uh so
1965 still maybe had drawing chances but
you can't miss those if you're Madness
you can't allow it and if you're young
you need to find that moment
exactly now we see a trade on B4 young
trades and I think this is just headed
for a draw the King goes to C7 and
there's nothing for either side to do so
okay if you're young here if you're
young here do you just milk out the
clock I guess but he doesn't
no he he just makes the draw by
repetition I think for both players it's
kind of uncomfortable to stall this
early in the match you just don't feel
like you're in the rhythm of the games
and yonda palmchi two to one advantage
right now he gets the white pieces he
goes back to E4 and we're getting a I
think we're gonna get another fight in
this game too
all right and so we have the Sicilian
Four Knights here Jan has a couple of
decisions so you can go Knight DB5 that
could turn the game back into his
fashiony cuff but he went
for Knight takes C6 the other Mainline
Magnus recaptured with the pawn and then
e594 and we see them with C5 by Magnus
ignoring the threat on the Knight but
attacking the Knight on e4
this is such a fun opening position
because my first instinct would be to
play Knight D6 check and after Bishop
takes D6 I'd want to take with the queen
but I can't because Knight C2 Fork at
the end I don't want to take on D6 with
a pawn and he's going for this exact
line at that pawn Benjamin do you see it
as a strength or a weakness because it
is very deep in enemy camp
yeah it's a great question Robert the
good thing also about the spawn of D6 is
that the spawn on C5 is practically
isolated that's a bush B3 there's no
such move as D6 here so it's going to be
awkward to defend so what exactly is
Magnus gonna do here you can defend it
temporarily with Queen A5 but white just
goes Queen E2 offers to create the trade
of queens and again the spawn is
terribly weak so not easy to deal with
this for for Magnus and hey we've talked
about this yesterday do you think there
is a chance that Giannis looked at this
for the World Chess Championship because
again first that match I'm sure he's
checked every single opening under the
sun
Jan's preparation has proven excellent
and he probably has looked at something
like this for the world championship
Queen F6 played by Magnus so he defends
tactically he's not actually protecting
the C5 Pawn but it's going to be an
equal trade one for one give me your B2
pod your king feels less safe and if you
play a move like Rook to B1 some kind of
slow move I think that black has Knight
to D4 even now after Queen D2 Knight
sits on D4 please take me I'll have E5
to follow it up and that D6 Pawn that we
were talking about it's no longer an
argument that one will be vulnerable
but look at how young deals with it he
traits on D4 and goes Queen side
Castleton how do you defend the pawn on
D4 if you go E5 white is going to blast
up the structure with the move F4 and
your Center is falling apart Jon's doing
great here
no F4 is such a good find and that way
if you take the D4 Pawn D6 Pawn remains
alive and that would be an issue so
suddenly Magnus in some danger here
yawns preparation has been good should
black you think just Castle kingside
give up the D4 pawn and eventually go
after the white king
I mean you can trap the king is sitting
pretty safe over here the policy Force
providing a nice Shield the king can
always move over is it like King B1 king
of one potentially
I don't know it's linked off remain it's
the annoying thing for him is that after
E5 F4 Queen 66 Pawn xc5 Queen 65 there
is the move rookie one so he is going to
go down a pawn here
although there's Bishop E4 at the end of
that variation with maybe an F5 but look
at this Magnus gives up the pawn in the
center and Janet looks confused he's
like are you sure about that Queen takes
D4 a queen Swap and Magnus Carlson
saying yes you're up a pawn but the A3
B2 Pawn combination there the one pawn
stops two and maybe there will be a way
for him to go Rook A5 Castle bring the
other Rook into the game and just
completely freeze white spawns
if mainers could get all those moves and
he's perhaps doing all right so let's
see what Jonah's gonna do in the
meantime perhaps he can just go Rook to
G1 or he might even have to protect the
spawning because in case Magnus takes
there is the move Rook G1 attacking the
bishop and you regained upon on G7 so I
guess now is a good time for Magnus to
Castle here or play Move Like F5 gaining
some space in the center followed by by
King of seven King F6 and then you can
go for the title with Bishop C6 Rook A5
Rook B8 and you have some sort of
blockade on the queen side so it might
not be that bad
Magnus Carlson may not believe in
fortresses but it looks like he has one
in this game so he plays F6 which
apparently is not recommended by the
engines I think the engines they're a
bit harsh in the sense that objectively
it was not the best move there was
something better there maybe Magnus had
a castle quickly to protect the G7 Pawn
that threatens G2 then you bring the
Rook to the C file but F6 looks like a
very natural move from the number one
rated player in the world
exactly he wants to go King to F7 bring
his King up to the board so then he can
go Rook to B8 then Bishop C6 I guess
Rook A5 it's all looking pretty solid C5
by Young a nice move he wants to go
perhaps Bishop B5 and go after the spawn
on A4 I I like what he's doing he's not
allowing Magnus to consolidate here
well now that actually explains why F6
was a mistake because it allowed white
to play C5 and look at the Eva bar it's
going up more and more in White's favor
that's going to be a past Pawn on D6 now
that D7 is removed but Benjamin I look
at this I still feel like Magnus has
very good chances to hold but how could
you not like White's position the A4
Pawn is loose as well
yeah this looks great for young he is
now in check so I guess he has to go
King B1 or King D2 the opponent A4 is
about to drop he's got this pass ball on
D6 uh but yeah if he takes up on e4 he
will have two connected passers on the
queen side this is looking very
problematic for Magnus Robert and if
Magnus lose this game you will go down
two points in a match
and that could be a dream come true for
you on the palm machine a nightmare for
madness you don't want yon to feel the
rhythm as soon as he starts feeling good
about his chest we know how dangerous a
confident young to prompt is he's run
away with the candidates tournament he
won before the even the final round was
played so do not give Yan this
confidence right now how could he not be
confident with that D6 pawn two squares
away from promotion
exactly yeah so let's see what main is
going to do you can think of G2 but I
suppose you just go rookie one attacking
upon the E6 and once you go E5 then you
take an A4 and it's so annoying for
Magnus that for the moment this D6 spawn
remains on the borders this is looking
super tough and again Robert look at the
clock yarn again up a minute
he continues to do well on the clock and
Magnus Carlson he looks kind of upset
right now he does attack this Rook on D4
that's the good news but when The Rook
just slid over to B4 this A4 Pawn at the
end of it is going to be loose but Jan
apparently made a mistake Rook to G1 the
very natural move was that wrong smile
I think he played way too quickly here
after E5 why does he first of all not
take an A4 and that's the bishop Bishop
takes G2 I think you should also have
considered the move Rook to D1 now
Magnus might be out of the woods there's
a check but King E6 black should be
doing absolutely fine here because the
Rooks finally get active
it looks so scary to allow two Rooks on
the seventh rank but the Kings already
escaped the background so there's not
going to be a Checkmate and suddenly you
know we've seen this so many times can
Magnus carlsen's play for more he's
gonna have the active King he's gonna
bring a rook of his own down to the
second Rank and if he can get both of
his Rooks in the first rank we could
even see a back right Checkmate threat
thanks to that pawn on A4 I think this
is actually a position all three results
are possible
exactly you know the polony4 would
freeze the Viking on A2 so that'll be
pretty tough for for Yan also these
spawns on F2 and H2 are Victor majority
on the queen side for the moment is
quite useless
so I think Magnus is doing absolutely
fine like you said he has the potential
to even play you for when he goes Upon A
D7 yawn all right so let's see what
Magnus is going to do here maybe G5
preserving the Jeep on or just going
Rook to D6
but Rook D6 is meant by Rook takes G7 so
that would keep that pawn on the board
so he does play your first move G5 is a
great choice and this is why I believe
that this position has chances for both
sides to win D7 remains but look at
Black's extra pawns on the king sides
four on two on that side of the board
and the Eva bar suddenly is favoring
black because Rook C4 and that rook and
start going after those white Pawns
yeah we see a rookie six checked by by
young but yet Magnus has a lot of
potential here on the king side he can
go let's say rocker 4 or Rook H for
going after the pawn H2 and Jan for the
moment does not have a single active ID
the great thing here for Magnus is that
he can let's take a rook H4 and he
doesn't need to rush but with going Rook
takes H3 you can go H5 first as Jan has
to keep an eye on this point he also has
to keep defending opponent D7 so I don't
know it has Magnus turned this one
completely around
he has indeed that's a good move though
Rook to D3 instead of Defending
passively because Rook F4 have like Rook
H3 and Target that loose H7 Pawn I
really like Rook to D3 and I think for
black Benjamin the move you've been
shouting for H5 that looks very strong
because White's main idea is Rook H3 and
if you go Rook F3 Black Ops play Rook F4
and trade the Rooks on that square to
protect the vulnerable F6 Pawn
yeah H5 looks like a nice move like I
said for the moment Rook H3 is a big
threat for yawn and there we have Magnus
is so precise in the end game and I
don't know Robert holding this game
would already be a big big success right
now for young whereas before it looked
like he was on his way to another
victory
it's a turnaround just like in game one
where Magnus he had the upper hand with
the white pieces and suddenly Jan was
able to steal a bishop in the game now
Jan has to figure it out where he was
first better and now he's to make that
switch in his mind so we have Rook F3 on
the board Rook F4 looks very strong to
me you if Rook takes G takes F4 and look
at Black's pawns they're marching up
very very quickly there they're gonna be
dangerous
exactly but what about this idea Robert
what about Rook takes D7 and if you take
an F6 you can give a check King E2 and
Rook C1 and Magnus is going down wait
check on rookie Rook T1
oh that she was a mating net potentially
so maybe there's a way out there for
white but this looks great for black the
Eva bars all the way down because
White's King is cut off Benjamin it
doesn't matter about the pawn quantity I
say this often in the end game go take
the H5 Pawn I don't care but what's King
E6 Pawn E4 how are you stopping these
passers
I don't see it just go Rook of two here
Jan can go after the opponent A4 but it
will be super slow look at this Robert
Jana's upper Palm but his majority on
the queen side is completely Frozen his
Rook on H3 is frozen his kingdom B1 is
completely stuck this is a dominant
position for Magnus Carlson
and what is he aiming for this Black's
turn King to E3 just winning the after
you run it's Rook H5 potentially so you
need to be a little bit precise here he
plays E4 because it's again not about
the quantity it's about the quality the
F Pawn is hard to stop
exactly it's very difficult to make a
move here for yawn if you go Rook to h8
then you then Magnus cannot go Rook G2
followed by F2 and you can't quite stop
the point you can also create any
counter play over here again you're
completely Frozen on the queen side this
so Magnus looks to be on his way to
another Victory here
Magnus Carlson the best end game player
of all time adding another one to his
storybook career he just knows when to
liquidate he knows what pawn formations
are best for him and right now he knows
that he's gonna even up this match two
to two Benjamin I don't think we could
have asked for more from these first
four games
no for sure and it will be interesting
to see how Jan will deal with this we
know that sometimes he can go and tilt
and this can be quite a tilting loss he
had a good position perhaps a winning
position out of the opening and instead
of instead of winning he did not only
throw it away to win but then he also
threw away the draw and Magnus is now
even up the score
and I think the good news for Jan after
that loss is it is half time Midway
through the time controls they get a
break so we have seen 45 minutes of
action the score is two to two both
players talking to the team behind the
scenes and we see it here with that
Victory nope it's not one to two you're
gonna see that update live in front of
you that will be two to two score Beyond
the Palm Street Magnus Carlsen they're
evened up
exactly Manus was his first win of the
match I think he cannot be too unhappy
Jan could have also won this game with
the white piece yellow winning position
but John perhaps played a little bit too
quickly
yes he he did bring us to a tie with a
2-2 score and Magnus Carlson he could be
happy once more he's taking on Jana
palmsi for a trip to the semifinals here
at this feature Championship presented
by coinbase more in just a few
foreign
[Music]
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
[Music]
by focusing on classical chess but later
we fell in love with playing Blitz and
bullet online
chess has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash
Barbarian might not Crush you on the
board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board speaking of crushing this
giant is a living Siege Tower usually
found in groups goblins are fond of
sharp pointy objects and other people's
pieces
the battle heart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her pose fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
have a 2-2 deadlock right now in the
matchup between Magnus Carlson and Jana
Pomchi Yana palmchi he's no stranger to
Magnus Carlsen he's no stranger to the
speed Chess Championship back in 2019 he
ended up in the semi-finals before he
was eliminated by hikar Nakamura but
Benjamin he beat dingly Wren along the
way in addition to having the biggest
margin in SEC history in his win over in
Elena danilia
exactly yeah he beat them around in the
match I'm sure he would have loved to be
doing in another match that took place
this year and I'm sure you also would
have loved to be Magnus in another match
a couple years ago but he's had he had
he's having his chance here for Revenge
Robert he um the score right now is even
same as in the world championship for
quite a while so let's see how he will
deal with this uh this loss perhaps the
break came at a good time for him it
gives him some time to recuperate it
feels a little bit a little bit
unnecessary to lose that one as he could
have also won
yeah he did have a great position if he
stole a d-pawn had a passer of his own
but Magnus Carlson does what Magnus does
best he wins and games even unwinnable
looking ones so yonda palmshi he does
have his work cut out for him having an
even score right now is a good thing and
I believe Benjamin that he needs to stay
in that even margin if he goes down this
match that's where it gets dangerous
because Magnus Carlsen we know how
difficult he is to beat once try to beat
him several times in a row I wish you
the best of luck
yeah and I'm sure I think though the
young gives himself the best Chance by
going up a game or two holding on to
that lead for as long as possible and
hoping that Magnus will get a little bit
nervous but if Magnus takes the lead I
think it's going to be smooth sailing
for him so let's see how the next couple
of games will go
and we are about to have liftoff in the
fifth game of the five minute plus one
second increment time Patrol there's
Jana Palm she and here are the opening
moves we have Knight F3 from Magnus in
this game so instead of our E4 e5s and
petrovs and turning into French's we
have in English
exactly and here to move E3 an
interesting move by Magnus I wonder what
exactly he has in mind in case Jan plays
the move D5 perhaps he wants to play
something like Knight C3 so let's see
what John will do here you can also go
for a set of with B6 and there we have
the move B D5 and now the move B3 by
Magnus
and he's just trying to feed keto on
this long diagonal staring towards the
black king and in these positions
sometimes white is able to hand black
and isolate upon on the D file but say
we see D4 so we have the box all these
pawns staring at each other so bedroom
in this opening do you like black or do
you typically like this from White
I think Blake's doing pretty well
serious he thinks before it's a nice
move but yawn he could take on C4 and
after Magnus recaptures play a move like
A6 followed by B5 and Bishop B7 and it's
turning into a bit of a Queen's Gambit
acceptance but I think black is a pretty
reasonable version the Nano C3 is often
a little bit misplaced as it's blocking
the bishop on the long diagonal and very
often you would rather have it on D2 so
let's see what Jana's gonna do I think
this this approach with dt64 and A6 is
very solid
it's becoming sort of a Queen's Gambit
accepted type of position and the big
part of these type of structures is that
black has some weak squares the C6
Square in particular and we see the
light Square Bishops coming off and Rook
to A7 played but I think white should
take on B7 put a queen on F3 put a rook
on C1 and D1 and that C6 square is
tender and black needs to look out for
it
exactly I'm a little bit surprised by
the move Rook to E7 by John I think
you've also addressed the issue with
Queen B6 that's what he does now but
Hattie played Queen B6 on the last move
he could have already played Knight 57
or Knight C6 and he should be doing
completely fine now Magnus might have a
move or two to create some problems for
young but if he doesn't do anything
quickly I think Jana is going to be
doing absolutely fine here with an ipd7
coming on the next move
a problem for white is that all of the
pieces look like they're in pretty
optimal squares you need to look where
to improve the Rook on F1 that's the one
piece but Rook to E2 that looks a bit
silly it's a very Queen E2 Rook D1
something like that it does feel though
as you said that black is entire so good
knight to E2 he's opening the C file
it's about that C6 Square potentially
and what do you make of this
yeah so we see a trade on F3 I think
magnus's idea was that in case young
would have played Knight bd7 there would
have been Knight C6 and that is why yon
traded first now he goes Knight C6 bring
his Knight into the game I think Robert
you've highlighted you've highlighted
this before Magnus is going to try to
apply pressure on that C6 Square he goes
Queen to C2 pressuring the Knight maybe
a knight to D4 jump in the near future
so Jan still has a few problems to solve
here Rook C8 would be a big blunder
Bishop D4 would be a winning tactic
because the Knight is pinned to The Rook
so Rook C8 would not be a good move even
though it looks like a normal one to
protect at night Rook C7 is possible
because Bishop D4 after Rook C7 you can
actually take that piece because there
are tactics on the E2 Square so you need
to time these things correctly if you
are both these players but right now Jan
needs to avoid any sort of tactics that
losing some material oh he walked right
into it
oh my gosh
Robert you cannot do this you if you're
playing Magnus you cannot make blunders
like this
oh my God we just spoke about it the
Knight on C6 is pinned because of the
back rank check and Yan he looks up at
the ceiling but there is no Beth Harmon
Solutions here he is unfortunately gonna
lose this game this is just clean
material
yeah he's done a very clean exchange
Queen be won by Magnus now he's just
gonna trade us some pieces what a
blunder by janapomnishi he could have
just played The Rook to C7 and then like
you said there would have always been
these tactics for taking on D4 Integrity
two but now he's done in the change and
Robert I think he uh we've talked about
this before if you want to have a chance
against Magnus you cannot blunder like
this and you also you cannot just throw
games
that was an even looking position and
now he is just down a rook for a bishop
there's an open file it's a position
where a bit more closed maybe you would
say that blackhead chances of course if
he had a pawn and a bishop for The Rook
then sure but it's a clean exchange Rook
for Bishop there's an open C file Rook
C1 here looks very promising uh Benjamin
this should be a one-sided finish
yeah 92 a nice move by Magnus now he's
just going to move a rook to C1 Queen C2
traded the queens and you can already
pretty much resign here if you're young
to publisher you're very unfortunate
loss that seemed I mean there was a
little bit of pressure by Magnus but
yeah he just had some he just had to
find a couple of acronyms to solve all
of it
it was just a careless move there he
just wasn't looking for tactics he was
looking for positional pressure and look
at his McQueeney for Magnus even when he
is winning positions he continues to be
precise that Knight wanted to land on C3
to close down the C5 maybe get a pass
Pawn now that Knight is pinned the queen
on B7 has to stay put tied down to the
C8 square and look at this maneuvering
you can trade on C3 if you want he says
no Queen on A6 protects it all E2 and A2
beautiful instructive play from Magnus
Carlson
yeah great stuff here by Magnus young
goes Upon A G6 he steals the he still
has that Knight on C3 I guess now he's
going to recapture with the pawn queen
E3 I think if Magnus gets the
opportunity he's probably going to give
his work for the pawn Rook C2 Magnus is
winning here but how do you actually
convert this Robert there's still some
work to be done
and I wonder if Magnus has completely
mapped this out where he recognizes that
certain end games if he takes on C3 even
if he's only up one Pawn in the queen
end game it's winning because he just
has that kind of knowledge but he's here
in this position he might bring his King
to help out in the center Queen to C4
that takes care of everything B3 will be
defended and that's C3 Pawn it's going
to be surrounded
exactly and now you can go Queen to C4
King E2 and he should win this game
pretty easily so let's see what John is
going to try to do here maybe King G7
moving the king up a little bit there's
nothing but I can do it yon just has to
sit and wait here and wait for Magnus to
show him how you know this game is one
now I think Rook Dixie 3 is a good way
to make things a lot easier for white
and there we go
just two extra pawns over there on the
queen side this is one where if the
white king could be checked a bunch of
times maybe you have a chance but at
this stage King uh King E2 might
actually have some problems with the g2
Pawn being targeted so it's not as easy
as it would initially appear perhaps
yeah still some work to be done for
Magnus he goes King he took and now I
guess Queen E5 like you pointed out for
yawn hitting that pawn on G2 which is
awkward to defend you can go for the
move F3 but then there's Queen G5 other
I guess then there's king of one so many
should be winning winning here in many
different ways even just A5 you guys
have three so I guess after Queen G5
here he is gonna go for the move king of
one
yeah it's then you don't see too many
more checks I mean even here Queen G3
check so what king to F1 the problem is
that the black queen needs to be in
three different locations at once and
he's been H1 but then also go back to G3
when the King goes to F2 you just can't
get everything their white spawns go up
the board Magus Carlson is going to take
his first lead in this match
exactly B4 he's just pushing the pawns
up slowly but surely King Jade Jan just
shuffling back and forth there's nothing
you can do to perhaps just B5 here or
queen D for another nice move offering
the trade Queens but also attacking this
Pawn on H4 and if you take the pawn on
H4 black never has any Perpetual ideas
anymore
that's true the king can sling away to
the H2 Square eventually and you just
block a check on the diagonal so Magnus
is up three Pawns in a queen end game a
few checks that's about it so Yonder
Palm she resigns and Magnus Carlson up
three to two Benjamin here is the
ultimate test for Yan he now has lost a
couple games uh oh he's playing a King's
game I was about to say can he rebound
or is he going to tilt he's going for I
need to win right now
exactly yeah well this is also what he
played against me and title Tuesday this
week when he was in a must win situation
in the last round we see Magnus
repeating I think this is also what main
is played against hikarakamura and
Norway chess janong for a knight of two
he is still playing Super quickly so
perhaps he's looked at this before the
match
and Jan he returns to openings from his
childhood or these King's gambits he
plays the French defense as black he's
not afraid to play offbeat lines but the
problem with this particular opening is
White's King is in the center Rook Jade
earned an exclamation point going to the
open file maybe there's Rook G3 to come
and it just feels like black is the one
having the fun at least for the time
being
exactly yeah black is easy development
uh the bishop kind of move out upon an
E4 is tender so I don't know it feels
like this this king's Gambit has
backfired quite a bit I remember also
Norwich has when Hikaru tried to King
his gamut against Magnus Magnus was not
in trouble for a single moment in the
game he knows quite well how to tackle
it
look at this position the G2 Pawn is
loose so the bishop on F1 can't develop
the E4 Pawn is attacked and also pinned
so not only will there be tactics on the
Square and he was Queen of B3 I'm still
liking the look of Rook to G3 because
then it also throws Knight takes D4 here
I have I just said it earlier but now it
carries an additional threat rookie
three checks gonna hurt this looks like
another potential one-sided game for
Magnus I think if he just goes on the
offensive Jan is going to be hurting
yeah I like this move from G3 that you
pointed out that it does threaten to
move Knight takes D4 it also introduces
this idea of Rook to E3 check and the
King has to perhaps go to D1 you know
Bishop two but then you're in a pin so
it looks great so far for Magnus the
materials even white is completely tied
up you cannot develop a single piece and
there we see it rather Rook to G3
it's so unfortunate for Jan he's pinned
along the third rank as king is stuck in
the center and when I mentioned Rook G3
several moons ago it's just because that
pawn is up on H4 one of the bad things
about pushing pawns is you give away key
squares so Black's Pawn structure looks
compromised with double F pods but
Benjamin we see that you get counter
play around it whenever you have double
pawns you've opened files there's an
open e-file there's an open G file there
may be these isolated pawns the f file
but that is not what's important it's
King safety and the aggressive
intentions are all in Black's favor
yeah and I already don't see what John
should do here Knight takes before is a
very clear threat perhaps you have to
move your queen but he's just moved it
so is he gonna move it again it's like
Queen A4 but black just goes Bishop to
D7 black almost has all of their pieces
into the game white only has these two
knights developed your king is stuck in
the middle it's very difficult to
develop Bishops so is yon perhaps
already a little bit until Robert
and playing the king's Gambit was a sign
to me that maybe he was does he really
believe in the king's Gambit that's
another question but against Magnus
Carlson I would not be playing such a
risky opening it's backfiring completely
as you mentioned the pin on the third
rank if the queen moves I don't even
know where he moved to if the queen goes
to C2 for example then Knight D5 into E3
is just another idea that I could go for
the pawn on e4 is pinned and oh my
goodness this looks miserable
this looks super tough for yon and what
really indicates that he is struggling
here is the clock usually Yawn is up on
time but now he's almost down one and a
half minutes on the clock he goes Knight
F3 hanging the pawn on e4 can Magnus
just take it
I actually like this decision he's gonna
swap Knights I believe and then he's
gonna try to tuck his King away there's
not another check in the position but
look at magnuscope Bishop E6 giving up
B7 he doesn't care about a single Pawn
he wants to go after that white king So
Benjamin it's all about timing and B7
should not be captured
and look at this variation Robert if
Magnus grabs the spawn on B7 Magnus
One's Gonna rookie detecting the queen
and if you take the C7 there's rocktex
B2 and if you take the hook there's
Queen E3 Checkmate so Magnus for sure
cannot take this Pawn but then where's
he gonna go with the queen
that is such a beautiful line if you
can't take on B7 because attack is The
Rook takes B2 check then you probably
just have to move your queen to D1 no he
plays Bishop to C4
can you I want to take it by Knight E5
but I'm not sure if it works it probably
does
yeah it I assume it does because you
kind of think of the pawn that hangs up
the queen on C4 and if you take the
Knight you hang up on a G2 with
devastating effect so what do you do
queen B5 but maybe then just C6 followed
by 93 or or something yeah that looks
crushing Robert
it looks like it's going to be a swift
victory for Magnus he's doing the right
thing by calculating right now about
Bishop takes C4 followed by Knight to E5
it's very direct it's one attacking move
after another you hit the queen when the
queen gives you a check you hit the
queen again oh he castles Queen side
instead and I can't hardly blame him
Knight E5 still a threat the white king
not very safe at all
this looks terrible for white Brook to
G8 is coming attacking the Pullman G2
Jan has still has not completed his
development and his King is super weak
on F2 so the king's Gambit has backfired
tremendously
the King has been gamuted that King is
going to be stolen and black is going to
Checkmate it and it's going to be
another win for Magnus that would be
three in a row and I don't know how Jan
is going to bounce back from that but
King's Gambit is not the answer
and there we have the move Knight to E5
you cannot take the d-pawn you hang your
queen and again you stick to the Knight
you hang the Palm in G2 so there's
nothing here for there's nothing here
for John I mean you're gonna have to
move to Queen then black can take an F3
with a rook or with a knight and black
just gets a crushing attack and black is
even up Upon A Magnus takes a two-point
lead
resignation was the only solution to
that position can't look at it anymore
Magus Carlsen up four games to two and
now with the white pieces Magnus he's
going to his fiancaro setup and will he
go to a Catalan that's the big question
no he instead goes to King's Indian
attack
yeah and he goes for this move A4 quite
a funny little move I wonder what
exactly the idea is we see young playing
the move Knight C6 very quickly we can
now go E5 grab space in the center but
Robert it's going to be interesting to
see how young will deal with all of this
I mean he lost that game with the white
pieces Magnus came back and yeah now
he's losing game master game
and look at this position here it's one
where it's a solid position for both
sides and that tends to favor Magnus
against anybody on the planet so Black's
Mission great opening thus far from Jan
he is not worse you see the eval bar
right down the middle and he can't
afford to beat himself playing the
king's Gambit like that it's what you
were talking about yesterday Benjamin
where you play some kind of risky
opening he lost in 13 moves to origin he
lost a pretty quick one to Magnus and
what just happened there why did the
eval bar go all the way down for a
second
so it seems that rookie might have been
a Miss I think Jan had the opportunity
to go B6 following a to A6 which
would have been very uncomfortable for
Magnus to deal with as where'd he go
with the queen right you cannot go to E3
going back to you one looks quite
passive you can go Knight C4 but then
your pin and if you go to C4 then you
create a lot of weak squares now Jan
goes for Bishop to G4 also a nice move
as he can potentially take control over
the square on D4 and he protected his E5
Pawn which is under Threat by three
pieces at least before white played C3
because the pin on that F3 Knight so C3
play to stop that Knight D4 move you
talked about the bishop on B2 looks
quite silly it's funny playing it and
opening like this where it looks like
white is not doing anything right and
yet the Evo bar is saying it's
completely fine for Magnus he gets away
with these type of opening because
objectively they're just fine
exactly Ayanna is doing absolutely fine
here he goes Queen E6 stepping the queen
up a little bit I think the reason why
white is doing fine here is because this
letter C6 doesn't have anywhere to go to
for the moment the pawn the squares on
B4 and D4 are restricted on the other
hand the Knight of C4 is quite active it
can potentially move around to E3 and D5
or F5 so we sit with rocket if you want
by Magnus I wonder exactly what he has
in mind and also this bishop B2 for the
moment it looks silly but it can always
reroute via C1 to E3 or G5
it's likely to happen and Bishop H3 one
of Black's main ideas when you line the
queen and Bishop is not possible because
the Knight G5 jumps with a fork of Queen
and Bishop so Rook to E1 protecting the
E4 Pawn over protecting it you could say
and maybe he'll slice Queen back to F1
at some point and then play H3 himself
and just try to kick this bishop out of
there
right so let's see who Jan's gonna do
here's he takes a little bit of time he
goes Knight E8 I think a nice move he
wants to go in Knight to D6 to try to to
try to trade up this active Knight on C4
so now if Magnus wants to keep this
Knight on the board perhaps he has to
consider move like Queen C2 so he can
meet Knight E6 with 93 uh because
otherwise after the trade it feels like
Jan gets a pretty comfortable position
you can always recapture with the Rook
move the other hook to d8 and then
perhaps try to infiltrate the Magnus
goes H3 and Robert you've talked about
this before this Pawn is not hanging
because of Knight G5 so that's a very
nice move then but I still think that
your ideas are nice for black Bishop
takes F3 the attack with the queen so
you don't drop a Pawn on H3 and then
Knight to D6 and the problem for white
is that B3 Pawn is so tender you played
the buff C2 to C3 I think one of White's
best ideas is to push that pawn back
grab it back to C2 to keep your Pawn in
a chain and thus protect it
exactly so let's see what Jana's gonna
do here he can trade in F3 Bishop H5
also very logical keeping the pin on the
night Rook 81 by Magnus and now perhaps
it's time to go for that move Knight to
D6 but you can also do Robert is go F6
followed by Bishop to F7 to rewrite that
bishop and puts impression upon B3 but
96 was chosen by yawn
I like the look of this for black it's
starting to appear very solid I think
that if Magnus wants to play for more at
some point he might need to throw in G4
and wow Rook D5 you're hitting the
bishop on C5 you're stopping the Queen's
stare to C4 and B3 and you're also
threading the E5 Pawn with another piece
so G4 suddenly might be a pretty big
threat
yeah so let's see who yellen's gonna do
he takes on C4 I suppose that Magnus is
just going to recapture because they
take the bishop but I can think of B2
and should be doing absolutely fine and
there we see the recapture by Magnus but
great Point Robert if you move the
bishop to the wrong Square perhaps this
Pawn on E5 can be hanging in some
variations also Robert in case of let's
say Bishop f8 there might be a rook
takes d8 and if you take the Rook then
white can trade on D6 and give you
double isolated Pawn so maybe you have
to play Bishop to D6
wow process of elimination that pays off
for Yana Palms good call by you Benjamin
uh that looked like a very bad end game
for black so Bishop D6 keeps all the
pieces on the board I still like the
look of G4 for white especially because
E4 is defended so many times it's not
like you're inviting the bishop onto a
particularly nice square and then white
can consider Knight H4 and either take
that Bishop on G6 or bring the Knight to
F5 so maybe Knight H4 now makes sense G4
first I'm not sure which is superior but
either way I do think that Knight F3
needs to improve
exactly so let's see what Magnus is
going to do if Jan gets another move
here he might have the time to go Knight
E7 attack that Rook on D5 and once The
Rook slides back you can take a C4 and
Rune white spawn structure so Magnus has
to be a little bit careful here and that
is why he's investing sometimes so let's
see what he's gonna do
it's such an important variation that
this Knight E7 is a threat it'll be bad
news for the white Pawn structure and
that Bishop on B2 which is looking
particularly useless so what to do here
maybe a Keiko Bishop F1 I was hung a
piece but he was Knight D2 same idea
that way the queen is defended on C4 by
a piece rather than just a pawn
exactly so 1987 can just be met with
Rook D3 and in case you take white
camera capture with the Knight so Robert
what about this idea right here F6
followed by Bishop 7 bring the bishop
back into the game although it's not
it's not bad over here but I think the
bishop can have more effect on this
diagonal there's such an important point
that Rook takes D6 here uh that is he
was not available because the blackwork
would have taken back to defend the
Queen instead we see the Queens come off
the board and what is this ending white
gets a pair of Bishops but black gets
the open D file oh or not so fast
closing that D5 after Bishop F7 Rook D6
cd6 who do you think that transformation
of Pawn structure will favor
it's a good question Robert I feel like
black should be doing fine there we've
seen him with Rook 88 by Young and
Bishop A3 played quickly by Magnus Rook
to D7 if Jan gets another move here
Bishop 7 he's kicking The Rook away but
Bishop F1 a great move by Magnus he's
rerouting the fish with the C4 or B5 and
all of a sudden there's all these pins
lurking into position
and I'm looking at the clock and we
typically say Yawn is ahead on time not
against Magnus Carlson we see Magnus
with a 40 plus second lead this is bad
news for Jan in this game now it's over
50 seconds and there's a pin on B5 if
you take on D5 twice you lose your Rook
because the bishop comes to C4 this
starts to look bad for black as white
has the bishop pair in an open space
yeah this looks extremely this has
started looking Pleasant free on it's
really annoying for him that it's just
one move too late you would love to go
Bishop seven here but again there's
takes ambition to B5 so he goes Knight
ba not a move you want to make and B4
great move by Magnus he's he is opening
up the queen side so that he can create
an outside queenside passer that's such
a great move from Magnus and if he takes
on A5 he's threatened to win a pawn or
open the B file for his Rook so Jan
takes them B4 but we've talked about
this in other games the passer the
outside pass Pawn is the most dangerous
one and there's a bishop on F1 helping
that pawn go all the way up to A6
Benjamin I already have the inkling to
believe that Magnus Carlson is going to
win this game
yeah it is starting to look really good
for maintenance yawn can perhaps
consider the take on D5 followed by
Bishop 7. and I don't see right away how
you actually defend a pawn but Magnus is
always going to have good chance in the
end game with the a pawn pushing over
the board but Robert look at the clock
John all of a sudden down to 30 seconds
and he walks into a pin but after Rook
D7 rookies and Bishop to B5 there's Rook
D6 and it's thanks to the pawn on B4 so
that pawn would like to be thrown off
the board for just a second
unfortunately for Magnus it is there now
great awareness what has changed by
pushing upon it's blocked the bishop on
A3
exactly and also with this recapture
white is weakened the deforce curve
which is what Gianna is aiming for is
the Knight lands on D4 all of a sudden
there's all sorts of forks there's
Knight F3 check there's Knight C2 so
Magnus has to be careful here so let's
see what he's going to do I think taking
on D7 makes a lot of sense Bishop B5
black has to play Rook D6 but what is
the follow-up there is Rook C1 but I
suppose after 94 black should be doing
okay you can take the pawn on C7 black
and take and follow up with let's say
fish p8 and you can defend the pawn on
B5
so he starts with Rook C1 it's their
Knight D4 there might be takes C7 watch
out for tactics here as The Rook on D7
is kind of pinned with the Rooks there
he walks into it but
what is this
all right Magnus goes for these up upon
the Arctic State now is forced king of
seven the only move perhaps Jan still
has quite good compensation here with
the Rook coming to uh well Nazi one uh
well where's the road going then
actually probably to C3 because you're
You're Gonna Go Rook C3 into the bishop
slides back to B2 you throw in Knight F3
check then bring Rook to oh Rook B3
hangs up Bishop C4 check idea this is
very complicated many tactics easy to
overlook some checks and forks and
everything pretty much
right but Rob maybe he is that he used
to go Rook C3 attack the bishop in case
of Bishop B2 then Knight F3 and then
Rook C2 and you keep chasing down the
bishop if it goes to A3 then you go Rook
C3 you take it again if it goes to A1
you go Rook C1 and maybe that way young
will be able to save a draw
oh very important move Bishop to F3
because G4 was not in time to shut that
Bishop out he goes Bishop B2 going after
this Knight I don't think that Yan can
afford to give the Knight on D4 but you
can't get Rook C1 in without that Bishop
leaving the board so it's one of those
trade-offs
yeah it goes 92 okay now Magnus perhaps
has to trade off that 9th First bishop
it would weaken the light square if
around his King
but if he goes King H2 and there we see
the trade if y'all now gets the time to
go like Rook C2 follow Bishop 3 he
should have real counter play but one
thing you have to be careful of Robert
is that after Bishop E3 if white plays a
five all of a sudden white would be
threatening Checkmate on a fade oh this
is Checkmate net F5 Rook f8 Checkmate
that's why Rook takes G3 was not played
but wait he walks into F5
okay guess you have to go G6 or G5 is
there even Bishop takes E5 in a position
like this the bishop on D1 is hanging at
the end of the line The Rook on d8
Snipes it from across the board
right but black gets a lot of Pawns you
can recapture take on G3 maybe go Rook
E3 after Magnus down to 14 seconds maybe
he can also go A5 take some B6 he goes
G4 okay but now you're gonna take the
pawn
yeah the A4 Pawn is looser he wants some
kind of checkmating neck that doesn't
seem to fully exist and now that A4 is
gone B5 next I think Jan is out of the
woods
exactly and with both players getting
along time this is any one's game Rook
B7 a clever little Track by Magnus the
bishop moves the E2 Bishop B7 if
anything it still looks a little bit
uncomfortable for Yan here
if the king gets out to F2 now oh the
Rooks on B6 down on B7 there there goes
the backup he walked into it a different
way and the pawn on F5 lives on because
of Rook G5 this is going to be a win for
Magnus Carlson oh no this looks like
game one in reverse
and Bishop h8 what a great move hanging
on to the bishop okay king of fate and
now you just go to Rook A7 followed by
F6 wait but you are a little bit stuck
though how exactly do you make progress
Rook E7 maybe young can push it upon the
bishop stuck over here but now Magnus is
pushing up his King and there should be
a win yeah it should be the king can
also help out F7 f8 and that is the game
Magnus Carlson goes up by three points
he has now won four straight games is
Benjamin that's very very bad news for
you on the palm machine
that's bad news for yawn indeed he's
having his chances in these games but he
fails to capitalize on them and Magnus
is just a little bit more precise in
those final moments and that is why
right now he's having a three-point lead
in the match
and we see that Jana Paul machine he
essays the Italian Game No More Kings
Gambit from him but he needs to score
Victory from what is typically seen as
quite a solid position rather than a
tactical one
exactly yeah and I think the King's game
is clearly backfired Jan is playing an
opening right now that is objectively
sound it goes 93 this is quite
reminiscent of their last game in the
2021 World Chess Championship
maintenance go Rook to eight I guess he
wants to go Bishop six Traders the
Bishops again not the most exciting game
so far but this is often how the Italian
goes like both players are trying to
play for small advantages
and you see these players know it very
well because the bishop trip is offered
white brings the bishop to B5 black
quickly retrieves the bishop to D7
despite having just moved the piece so
look at this no pawns have been traded
it's an even position in terms of
material but where do they go for from
here white might strike with D4 but
black is aiming at the E4 Pawn
exactly a Magnus now rerouted his Knight
of C to G6 this gives him the option to
go C6 kick the bishop away and then
perhaps go D5 at some point in the
future and build in the center G3 an
interesting move by yawn it's the price
of Nano G6 of the F4 square but he's
weakening some light squares around his
King
the light squares could be blacks for
the taking especially if you could hop
your knight forward but unfortunately
the pawn on G3 takes away the Knight on
g6's four jumps and Benjamin my coach
always you to tell me Knights on B3 G3
B6 and G6 they're often the worst
squares for Knight because not only do
they not get able to jump forward based
on a pawn but they end up staying there
a bit too long
exactly yeah so we'll see how this plays
out in the meantime goes Pawn to B4
expanding on the queen side the good
thing though about this energy6 is that
it will always protect the spawn on D5
and that is why wait but Bishop's D5
Robert isn't that just a blunder oh the
queen on C7 is loose so what is Magnus
thinking here
oh let's let's go back let's bring up an
analysis board just to show everybody
what that looked like when two of the
best players on the planet they just
didn't really think they didn't spend
enough time Bishop takes D5 you couldn't
take back as you're showing because the
queen was loose on C7 so black is lucky
that you don't actually lose you know a
bunch of material but that was a Central
Pawn and that would have been good news
for you on the pop machine
exactly and again he has to take
advantage of these opportunities when
they present them now Magnus is it has a
very comfortable position he goes Queen
E6 taking the pawn Rook everyone
ambition to E6 and Robert I already
slightly prefer Black's position he's
got a very nice Center here the pawn on
B4 is a little bit loose the opponent A4
was a little Blues that's why John moves
it up to A5 and Main is this very easy
piece play
and the one thing going for Jan is the
B4 Pawn cannot be captured just yet
because Bishop takes D5 the queen will
be in line with the Rook Rooks win
showdowns with Queens but that was a big
Miss I think that's one of those moments
where we can't beat around the bush we
can't sugarcoat it Jan needs to find
those moves when when Magnus blunders
and maybe because it wasn't a huge
change in evaluation chess.com doesn't
give it a blunder that's what we call
blunders right top Grandmaster say I
just blundered that idea he just didn't
see it coming and Jan unfortunately he
didn't see it either
yeah quite quite shocking because it
seemed to be quite Elementary
but okay the good thing Rihanna said the
position is still even that being said
it's difficult for bow ties to come with
a plan here so let's see what he's going
to do maybe like King G2 move his King
up a little bit like you said earlier
the spawn on B4 for the moment is not
hanging because if you think there's
always going to be push takes to be D5
so we see mattified by yawn that is that
in case black takes you recapture with
the pawn attack the Knight of G6 and
once the Knight moves then this opponent
E5 is hanging so let's see what Magna is
going to do maybe just Queen D7 threaten
to take the Knight and I don't see
anything better than just moving the
Knight back to E3 that's probably what
he's gonna go for because there isn't
anything better there and that would be
a funny repetition of Queen D7 93 Queen
D6 Knight F5 not one you see every day
but why should Magnus make a draw here
his Center is perfect look how solid it
is from B7 to D5 his E5 Pawn is defended
so if I'm Magnus I'm looking for more
I'm not just trying to draw this game
from the black side and he can really
put the pressure on Jan three points is
a lot but in bullet anything can happen
if you get sends this the four and yon
can tilt that would mean it's magnus's
match and Yan I don't know how he would
be able to get back in it
yeah and it's holding tough already for
John he's going up on time here in this
one though he's already up a minute
managers has to move the queen he
couldn't really go anywhere I can go to
D7 C7 or even f8 I wonder if after Queen
D7 yon perhaps is considering a move
like Knight H4 to keep the game going
perhaps that could be worse
consideration yeah it also loosens up
the E5 Pawn because the Nintendo G6 is
defending that pawn it's his only
Defender if the queen is to slide away
so I like the look of a knight H4 and
Magnus he's really spending a ton of
time here does he have any other Square
we talked about Queen D7 maybe he's
looking in a different direction
your main is spending a lot of time here
he is dropping 90 seconds Below on the
clock I don't know okay he goes for it
he goes for bridge takes a five four but
isn't this just losing a pawn
does he want after Rook takes E5 maybe
Knight G4 and then after the Rook moves
back the Knight takes an F5 it looks
like that's what he's going for
right he goes 97 say Maria perhaps John
could even consider a move like D5
sacking the rule but if you take you get
these two pawns over here and if the
queen moves maybe a move like F6 I mean
I love it I don't know what to make of
this by uh by Magnus remember when Jan
didn't sack on G5 in a previous game
Knight takes G5 he had an option to get
two pawns to open the king here he goes
for it he's leaning back he plays D4 it
earns the two exclamation points and
this is what he needs to get him back in
the match moves like that you sacrifice
material instead of the board in a
bedroom as you said if 95 de5 and you
got a pawn to get up to F6 objectively
we see the eval bar saying black is okay
but in Blitz chest black loses that
position most of the time
yeah it looks super tough for black okay
here we see Magnus accepting the
sacrifice his Queen is under attack I
guess it's going to go to D7 hitting the
pawn you can also just defend upon with
a move like Knight D4 followed by rookie
one maybe F6 E6 at the right moment or
you can set up this battery Queen D3
Bishop C2 and then E6 or F6 and Magnus
in the meantime doesn't have any active
plan so I love this exchange Sacrifice
by yawn it's great Queen takes B4 is
available uh it it does go for it just
now but I think F6 still looks very
strong and the point is that Knight G6
is unavailable in that particular line
because a bishop takes D5 with a threat
not just against the queen but if Queen
takes G6 check the F Pawn would be
pinned so F6 here looks like a huge
opportunity for Yan but maybe Magnus is
willing to sacrifice his Queen and he'll
get two Rooks for it
and there we go F6 is on the board great
move by Young like I said in case it
takes takes at 96 there's Bishop takes
D5 the queen is under attack and you
also threaten to hit this Knight over
here so perhaps Magnus has to give up
his Queen on B1 and he will have to roxo
but his King on G8 is going to be super
weak
and the fact that Magnus hasn't moved
yet could you somehow missed this like
Queen xb1 is the only move you lose the
game because Queen takes G6 checks to
immediate mate he has to play Queen
takes B1 followed It Up by taking on D5
I think with the Rook maybe he's not
even that much worse the Evo bar is
pretty high Benjamin but I think they're
great drawing chances for black
I mean to be fair this does look really
nice for Roy if you get the queen A6 is
just going to be Checkmate so you can
even and there will see queen of C1
right away I guess Magnus has to play
King H7 or Rook D6 or Rook A6 so that in
case you take on a chicks black still
has to move Rock takes F6 we see King H7
Knight D4 this should be a win for yawn
I mean Knight of five and queen 866 is
coming and Jan knows it the way he just
looked he's like yup that Knight is
coming in to help do some of the heavy
lifting and it's Unstoppable don't play
95 now because Knight F3 track will win
the queen so he brings King up to G2 and
Knight F5 is next
but now Magnus has the time to go Rook
D6 because now he's just in time with
Rook takes F6 queen of four nice move by
Yan Rook d8 but black skin is so weak
over here and I love this move H4 so
that in case of a potential 96 you can
always push the pawn all the way up to
H5 really nicely done from Beyond right
now and now Queen F5 check you can pick
up the D5 Pawn if you want that as well
the Knight is loose on C4 the B7 F7
pawns are also hanging if Jan doesn't
win this game I I just don't know how
you beat Magnus Carlson
no he has to win this one he's up two
minutes on the clock Queen D7 nice move
but yeah now Queen is having the point
he said after King G8 there is a knight
to F5 and there's just no move for
Magnus Jana's gonna win this game this
is beautiful technique from Jan because
he could have taken the D5 Pawn but I
would have given black better chances
instead he just reads all of his pieces
in the H Pawn tonight and that's Game
Over Yonder Palm she strikes it's back
to a two-point lead for Magnus Carlsen
and Jan he should be feeling much better
about his chances
what I especially liked from him is that
when he got into a winning position he
took his time he took his time to find
the precise moves and he put Magnus away
we saw that earlier in the match he got
some good positions but he rushed a
little bit and that's where he led
mainly Magnus escape and even turn the
game around but we see that if he takes
his time he's able to to be Magnus
and we also see that when Magnus loses a
game he goes back to a more solid
approach look at this Queens are off the
board it's not going to give young
tactical opportunities he firmly
believes that he can beat magnesium he
can beat yon in end games that may look
equal but have more to them than
initially meets the eye
exactly yeah so perhaps the most C3 here
restricting the Knight on C6 it can no
longer go to B4 and you depend upon on
D4 once more Bishop G4 and nice
developing move by yon I assume he
should be doing fine here with a move
with a rook moving to eight but like I
said before Robert Magnus is playing for
these very small advantages his pieces
are slightly more flexible does not C8
Nana C6 sorry cannot go anywhere for the
moment rookie the 982 for the moment is
under attack though and Magnus was mad
at himself I think the reason why is
when he played C3 after the Knight went
to C6 it says Knight couldn't jump to E5
which was one of his major plans so
Magnus seems like he's a bit
uncomfortable with what's been happening
and this position does look good for
white in the sense that there's no
immediate risk in the position the
Knight can't go to F5 now because the E2
Knight was loose he plays G4 gains more
space that Knight can go to G3 from E2
as well I can't say that I love White's
position but I think he is a nice small
plus carpovian Style
exactly yeah he just has a little bit
more space for his pieces they they can
maneuver a little bit easier I guess
this Knight wants to go to G2 maybe this
Knight wants to go to G3 King F2 Bishop
d2 move this Rook into the game then
slowly but surely expand on the king
side this looks like vintage Magnus so
let's see how he will try to tighten the
screws in this end game he brings up
Knight back to G2 that allows him to
play Bishop F4 next if he wants to trade
those pieces he can also play H4 King F2
Rook H1 maybe strike and I think this is
a mistake that many players make because
they think oh just because the Queens
are off the board there's no such thing
as an attack I think white can go after
the black king with those Pawn pushes up
the king side
exactly yeah what we have here is called
a queenless middle game only the Queens
have been traded but for the rest all
the pieces are still on the board King
G7 by Young moving his King up the board
a little bit perhaps this move
before that you suggested earlier Robert
it would force the trade of Bishops
black would have to trade as otherwise
why it's going to trade themselves and
give you double isolated pawns on D6 and
then I will come to F4 and G5 all of a
sudden is a threat
I love it and so Bishop F4 looks
reasonable I might even start with H4
just because I'm not sure really if G5
is a threat from White's perspective but
it keeps that alive so it makes black
have to think but Madness is the one
thinking here we're about even on the
clock I do prefer White's position but
you need to create specific targets
H4 also a nice move by Magnus we see a
try bionic a G5 now the nine moves back
to G8 this might look passive but the
Knight can reroute from G8 to a 5 from
where it would be putting pressure on
opponent H4 Magnus recaptures with the
Knight and actually I like this move
Knight ce7 as now young can go upon a C6
to strengthen that pawn on D5 extremely
precise play from Jan because the knight
at C6 was bad it left D5 vulnerable he
reroutes that knight from C6 to E7 to C8
up to D6 they can see more play for
black and look at C4 from Magnus he's
striking in the center while black is
moving to the back rank I feel like
there are some attacking chances against
the black king especially if a knight
lands on E5
for sure yeah what I also like about
this move C4 and Knight 64 is that it
stops black from playing Knight to D6 so
now you have to find a different way to
get your knight into the game Jan of
course could also play Knight G7
followed by Knight F5 but the moment you
go Knight out of five white can always
take and you definitely do not want to
recapture with the pawn so Jan should be
doing fine here but he still has to
figure out how exactly he's gonna get
his pieces into the game
and so for Magnus King F2 comes to mind
Rook E2 followed by Rook to E1 doubling
on the e-file he plays Rook D1 instead
maybe he's hinting at some kind of D5
Pawn push at the right moment and also
well the Knight was stuck on C8 for the
time being but he's trying to free both
of his Knights so that night on E7 can
can move successfully and then the
Knight on C8 can join it afterwards
yeah exactly Rook did a nice move
getting out of the pin on the e-file
division good at five or two EA to
strengthen that F7 point a little bit
Robert he might have to be careful the
bishop might run into someone like
Bishop's G6 and there are tactics with
Knight E6 checks so let's see what John
is going to do here white certainly has
some attacking chances here it's a good
find the E6 square is soft so watch out
for those sacrifices on G6 and here
maybe on to take my Bishop that's not
important you have an isolated Pawn so I
could see an argument for Knight B6
please please take that Bishop I'll
blockade the square in front of your iqp
he goes Knight D6 instead because his
Knight E7 is actually covering the
square but this transition Knight D7
Rook D7 into the more of an end game
that does seem good for black
yeah I like how Giannis played this he's
actually I'll maneuvered Magnus perhaps
a little bit one of his Knights is
headed to F5 it was pressured upon an H4
and a Pawn on D4 the Knight on E7 is
loose but there's not a single Discovery
for Magnus that works here if you take
on G6 black recaptures with a knight
problem solved if you're taking F7 you
will capture the king and then that is
defended and they've taken D7 you're a
catcher with a rook and the Knight is
defended again so he goes King to F2
I think it's a good move bring your King
as a weapon in the end game but I like
Bishop F5 here you mentioned that black
needs the F5 score for a knight let's
first swap Bishops open the D file for
The Rook on d8 then plant a knight on an
outpost square that H4 pawn and both the
D4 Pawn they're very loose and black
staring at them
yeah black would love to trade with
these Bishops also because all of these
pawns are on light Square so I think
Magnus should keep those on the board
with Bishop F1 also because it stops
black from putting a knight on a five
Bishop F1 seems to be the correct choice
at this moment for Magnus Carlsen I'm
looking at the clocks Magnus he is up
just 10 seconds so it's pretty even on
the clock and Jan continuing to make
good moves let's get Rook to see it
maybe we'll have a C5 in the near future
or even a knight B5 don't count that out
because if white takes on B5 and C takes
B5 there's an open C file and only black
has a rook down that line
exactly so now we have an interesting
position both sides have gotten all of
their pieces into the game another
question is how do you further improve
it's not obvious to me at all I think if
black gets a move or two maybe he wants
to go Rook C7 defend the Knight on E7 a
little bit more maybe bishop to C8 and
then move a knight to F5 to hit the
spawn on H4 or actually maybe the D
Knight as then you also put maximum
pressure on the opponent D4
oh Knight C4 so Magnus trying to trade
off pieces and if you play D5 as white
I'm wondering if black will play C5 push
through and try to give chances for a
pass Pawn on the queen side so it's a
big moment here for Magnus that isolated
Pawn is a long-term weakness but maybe
you can't successfully push it and if
that's the case then you're gonna have
to make a move like I don't know Knight
back to E5 or Knight to E3 just trying
to create some sort of play for yourself
but Robert does this actually work and
John just take on D5 maybe take on C4
taken D5 and then create a pin along the
default it all looks very loose and also
like you mentioned before there is that
Rook C2 check so quite a risky approach
here by Magnus
I think he's gonna give up that pawn in
the center so Knight C4 Bishop C4 Pawn
takes D5 maybe just Bishop back to B3 it
does look bad for white now that
actually I'm seeing it happen on the
board and Jan he senses that he has an
opportunity he is now up upon and better
here's the thing Robert if you go Rook
D7 there's Bishop B3 but does he have
Bishop to C2 oh there's Rook D2 and then
your Bishop is hanging so
to check but now King King G3 Maybe
there's rookie too because of the Rook
takes E2 the king can take back
protecting The Rook on D1 so what was
the Miss there from Jan it was not easy
to spot
no for sure it was not so let's see what
he's gonna do here perhaps he's gonna
trade the king will recapture he can
think on D5 black should be doing
absolutely fine here but keep in mind
he's down in the match so he would like
to take advantage of any opportunity he
can get so can he perhaps cook up
something here it is officially the
final game in the five plus one and we
see pieces are being traded off Jan
realizes that he should be able to hold
the draw here but I prefer the Knight to
the bishop because in this end game the
Knight can hop from color complex to
color complex the bishop is stuck in the
light squares not attacking anything of
course it should be a draw but much of
Chess should be a draw without someone
making a mistake and mistakes happen
especially when the players are down to
a minute each
exactly and keep in mind that the spot
on H4 can turn into a weakness if black
can go King is six to F5 but I can also
play for win so it's not that easy here
for Magnus as well also the position is
fairly open and that often favors the
bishop so let's see what Magnus will do
he goes 94 now John has to trade his
opponent F6 is under attack and then
perhaps he has the time to step step up
his King
and King E6 there might be Knight C5
check so that could work out for black
but you need to be careful so he plays
B6 first of course and yeah there
doesn't seem to be any more forward
jumps T6 coming Benjamin you make a good
point the black could actually win this
game if White's not careful and that
King goes up to F5 and it's a G4
exactly so king of four by Magnus now
King E6 the black king can move up to
while it could not have moved out to D5
because of Knight of six but hero super
56 and Knight C3 for the moment Magnus
has stopped being that King from Robert
I think this is a missed opportunity for
Yan I think objectively this is probably
a draw but what does what I do here if
you move the king back there's King F5
you cannot move the Knight there's King
D5 so Magnus actually has to play quite
accurately here to hold the draw I think
I think they're reviewing the game both
them looking oh there were some chances
here or there I'm with you that Magnus
would have been the player who had to
prove that he could make a draw there
but the draw was agreed probably young
wanted to get through with that time
Patrol they're moving to quicker time
patrols here at the speed test change
presented by coinbase but Magnus Carlson
he has a two-point lead over yonda
palmushi and January just saw him leave
his chair he does not look particularly
happy
yeah perhaps he hit the you know when
the game ends you see the valuation pop
up and he saw that he has an advantage
there and against Magnus again you have
to take any opportunity you can get
and I think with colors reversed Magnus
would have played on there but it is a
five and a half three and a half lead
for the world's number one player Magnus
Carlson five and a half three and a half
bedroom that's a very successful first
time Patrol for the Norwegian
I think he cannot be unhappy at all he
started down a point in the match also
then in game four so Jan was actually
winning with white pieces and Magnus
completely turned the one around and it
has taken a two-point lead so uh yeah I
think Magnus can be quite satisfied
he's definitely satisfied he's going to
go into the three plus one with the lead
so he's thrilled and I can't think of
anything or anyone much smarter or
faster than Magnus Carlsen but if you
wish your financial systems were as fast
and smart as the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase they
can be check out coinbase.com update the
system or use the command coinbase in
chat to learn more we're going to head
into the three plus one but now we take
a break for more from the speed test
Championship presented by coinbase
Magnus Carlson versus young the Palm
Street just in a few
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
white to move
hmm
you gotta take ag1 daily for every daily
puzzle
[Music]
got it Bishop U7 King G7 Queen E5 Queen
E4 and the end white wins a piece
nailed it
everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games
hey we're trying to have a lesson here
you need to get out of here recently
more kids have been playing chess than
ever in school but sadly we've learned
that they may not always be playing
chess at the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen in the
classroom focus on your school because
chess.com will always be there when
class is over
[Music]
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speeches
Championship presented by coinbase Jan
is no stranger to the speed Chess
Championship and he's no stranger to
Madness Carlson these two played the
2021 world championship match against
one another of course Magnus Carlsen
retained his crown he defeated Yonder
Pomchi with games to spare but Benjamin
it's 2023 now these are two different
versions of their previous selves
maggots Carlson with a two-point lead
but what do you make of this match and
what do you think John has to do to
strike back
I think Young overall has been playing
Gucci so far however he has lost a few
games due to some unfortunate blunders
and sometimes we see him playing a
little bit too quickly however he did
close down the margin a little bit in
that game with the with the Italian so
you just need to keep playing his chess
and try to avoid avoid blunders
he has been His Own Worst Enemy at times
throughout his career but Magnus Carlson
is the enemy of most when we're talking
about facing someone across the
chessboard Magnus with the two-point
lead we're getting into the three minute
plus one second increment time Patrol
and well Magnus is hard to beat with
unlimited time in the clock but when we
get to those final seconds unlike some
other super jams he's also really good
at bullet scrambles
exactly yeah and also I would like to
add one thing John really has to take
advantage of every opportunity he can
get in that last game we see he still
had some some chances but he just took a
draw which was a little bit surprising
to me
and if Magnus you know had that position
from the black side perhaps he would
have played on but that is a thing of
the past just like their 2021 world
championship match and we're oh look at
this this is a fun opening and you know
if you blink you would have missed it
but there was a temporary night
sacrifice that black could not take
let's show everybody real quick young
played this move Knight E6 you're gonna
take the Knight as there will be
Checkmate on H5 so Magnus just played
the move Queen two B6 and now we have
this position why does the bishop pair
the black has pretty easy development
yes look at the pieces they're out it
looks very bizarre because black is
missing a dark Square bishop and you
castled with pawns with E7 and G7 this
may be like the only opening that you
could possibly do this in
yeah it's quite funny because white got
rid of the bishop the Knight were
captured on D7 and then moved out of G6
into like I said usually you have to
play E6 or G6 to get castled so um yeah
but overall Jan has the best repair
Magnus has a lead in development for now
so let's see what he will do I think if
yon gets the opportunity to to
consolidate here with moves like Bush B3
and queen C3 he might get the advantage
and for a second I forgot that Jan was
playing with the white pieces because I
saw a pair of Bishops I saw a player
trying to squeeze out an advantage but
Jan he is universal I know we've been
talking about him with the tactics he's
somebody who is a great end game player
you have to be great at all facets of
the game usually people have preferences
but Jan saying let's play solid chess
let me use the two Bishops to my
advantage and why not this does look
like a nice position for white
exactly but look at what Magnus is doing
he goes Bishop to G4 trade office Bishop
to go Knight H4 put pressure on this
bishop and if you go Bishop to E2 then
he goes Knight F5 putting pressure on
the pawn on D4 and the bishop on E3 so
Magnus doing a great job neutralizing
White's Bishop pair I can't get over the
E7 and G7 pawns like it doesn't look
like I'm watching a standard game of
chess it looks like Fisher random and
yet this is where we are and it does
look Pleasant for black as you said the
Knight comes back to F5 hitting the
bishop on E3 there are no D5 tactics
because the peace attacking the queen
will be removed from the board so I bet
you this looks like you know a balanced
position do you prefer the Bishops or
the knights at the stage
it's a good question Robert I think now
Jana's going to recapture with the pawn
I think I would slightly prefer Black's
position it feels like he's got the
easier moves here maybe even a move like
Pawn E5 putting a lot of pressure on
that pawn on D4 and there we have it on
the board Jan takes it right away but 94
taking the queen and where do you go
he has to go back to C1 you can't go up
to E3 Pawn that would be game over so
young looked a bit surprised but 94 was
the natural jump against the queen
yeah this looks bad for white
yeah this doesn't look good Rook takes
C5 and you're just stuck with this
isolated Pawn on E3 your Bishop 22 is
not doing a whole lot and Robert we've
talked about this before the John just
rushed there again with the move
politics E5
he didn't spend much time that's clear
but he is up over now 40 seconds on the
clock so Benjamin this is a quicker type
Patrol we have to take that into
consideration maybe some of his gate
plans let me push Magnus towards the
brink of a loss on time
exactly Queenie try push to F3 okay now
Magnus can just recapture the queen and
he's in full control maybe yawn should
have gone for something more active like
Bishop to H5 but yeah now it's all
Magnus he has white has this isolated
Pawn in E3 he's got the active Queen on
E5 the active Knight on e4 we see you on
trading but this is just a very passive
defense
yeah it looks like it should be sturdy
enough even though black is better I
loved collinear moves like that Rook D3
going right after the E3 pawn and if
white takes the queen infiltrates via D3
and white is stuck in the mud I love
that move Rook D3 and I like that Magnus
made it very quickly
yeah we see training on on the three
queen of fun nice move by yawn if you
trade the Queens you uh you're you're
King and go to E2 and if you take on E3
then white takes the queen of these
three and wins a rock so Jan or Magnus
has to move a screen if he wants to keep
the advantage
he moves back he does have a slight Edge
because the pawn structure black with
two points white with three namely the I
said Pawn on E3 and I think Queen E7 was
good Rook d8 to follow but how do you
actually crash through if you are Magnus
Rook cheetah is he went for like an
attack with Queen F6
I think so but Magnus can just eliminate
any counter play with move Queen to D1
you trade of the queens and black is
very quick to go Rook 2 D2 afterwards
and it's very difficult to see how
weights keeping their Queen side
together he goes Queen D6 instead
attacking The Rook maybe now just King
H3 goes queen of three
okay and queen E5 great centralization
for madness he covers the only weak
point the G7 Pawn in the position
everything is defended and now a rook
can slap the D2 but that's a nice move
by yawn because his Rook on G3 protects
B3 if there's a swap of Queen's in F4
exactly and also now his rook and come
back into the game with rookie three
Department A2 is on our attack we just
go A4 and like you said Robert the pawn
and B3 is weak but right now it is
defendant and rookie three a nice move
stopping the king from marching on the
board this should be a draw but it is
still a little bit uncomfortable for
white yes because black can play G6 King
G7 King F6 and the white king is cut off
so he tries to bring his King up via G3
and F3 I think that's smart but look at
Magnus he says please take my pawnage
for I'll take on G2 your king is running
out of real estate
right that's why John goes Kenya three
but A5 Magnus slowly but surely
tightening the screws young can of
course always go rookie too I think
Magnus is Gonna Keep Us working the
board with like Rook to D1 and maybe
then a move like King G4 can be
considered but man is definitely the one
playing for a win here rookie 2 is a big
decision because if you trade on E2 the
black king was King E7 King D6 King C5
King B4 I feel like black does have some
very good winning changes but it becomes
a race because the H4 Pawn was also weak
so instead Jan just plays G3 I think
that was the correct decision
considering the time situation and I
have to add Benjamin that Jan offered a
draw at some point and once again Magnus
played on
yeah it feels like Magnus has a slight
edge here the king is now moving up to
F6 move to F5 the pawn on the four is a
little bit weak so Magnus definitely
still has chances here he just goes B6
slowly but surely improving his position
Jan's got the open E4 for his Rook but
it cannot go well aha maybe this could
be a way to create some counter play
quickly and make a draw
so he was Rook B7 of Rook B3 he wants C5
but then black has B5 this is not simple
right so take stake C6 B4 though like
how exactly do you make the draw
probably go through the a pawn here like
Rook to A7 and Rook C3 we're gonna see a
pawn end game for black
right so now in case of A4 there's C7
okay goes F5 check I guess you go King
the H4 to defend everything and after
Rook C3 you can it goes King G5 also
fine now black probably goes Rook G3
Checkers otherwise there will be in
check on B7
that was a really essential check on B7
and we see this liquidation and I guess
this is what John is relying on he's
gonna get the beep on for the C Pawn but
is there some kind of Checkmate being
set up no the king just runs back to G3
and this should be equal but black is
better
Blake is certainly better but Dwight
just sits and there's no way to make
progress for Magnus here just forces to
draw and there we have it
okay so they played to the bear kings
that was a good hold from Beyond the
Palm sheet but a good result for Magnus
he leads in the match he burnt a bunch
of the clock off the match timer but a a
nice start I think for all the fans in
game one of the three plus one and by
the way if you're new to this Channel
right now throw a seven it's September
but also keep following the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
because this is another quarterfinal
match and after this one ends we do have
MBL versus nihal sarin so you will not
want to miss all the action here but
back to this board Benjamin we see that
we had an elephant Sicilian Magnus going
back to one of my childhood favorite
openings
yeah we see Magnus hero with the Pawns
in the middle he has active development
maybe The Rook can move to D1 he's
spending a little bit of time though Jan
still playing quickly there we have to
move forward rookie one so let's see now
how Jana's gonna play like maybe bishop
D7 but it all looks a little bit clumsy
so I think Magnus can be quite satisfied
about the outcome of the opening here we
see him with the D7 what y can often do
here is combine moves like beers to D3
and queen E4 to try to start some sort
of attack on the king side
and he goes Knight C3 so we are going to
see a transformation of Pawn structure
but I like what you're pointing out that
the bishop on D3 will stare at the black
king and if you play G6 to blunt that
Bishop you give up the H6 Square for the
second white Bishop this is starting to
look like the makings of an attack but
Benjamin we know if there is no attack
black is better because of the C3 and A2
isolated Pawns
exactly all of these bones can be a
little bit tweaked upon a two to policy
three also the pawn on E5 nice move here
by Magnus going H4 because eventually
you want to go keep Queen E4 black has
to go G6 and then you can follow up
quickly with the move H5 so you can also
play H5 here right away anticipating
that move G6
and look at the clocks Magnus he's down
nearly 40 seconds Jan is playing this
quickly where's the Checkmate says yawn
you're attacking with your queen and
your Bishop I've stopped that diagonal
if he doesn't take what the h-ford I'll
be very surprised but he honest thinking
so
can you even take with the F1
I'll be shocked because if you play
ethics G6 you critically weaken the pawn
on Easter but he goes for it wow Robert
this looks like a serious mistake
I'm wondering why he went for this like
what he was worried about on the H file
maybe he thought that white would
quickly get some pieces over there and
he's trying to bring his Rook towards
the black king but this bishop on F7 is
a big Pawn
yeah Rook A5 this looks very awkward
from Young Bishop to B3 now Magnus will
always have pressure on the pawn on E6
he can maybe move a knight to G5 at some
point this looks terrible for black
really terrible and the C3 Pawn is now
targeted it is a weakness but I think
that white can go with the Rook lift
Rook E3 both defending the C3 pawn and
when you move your knight out the way I
feel like The Rook would have been able
to jump towards the king side because
Rook D1 and it got a question mark still
looks good for white though
right so what happens if Jan takes on
the one how are you going to recapture
you can think of The Rook but then you
hang the pawn on E5 you can now stay
with the bishop but you would like to
keep the bishop in active position but
what is this move A5 by yawn I don't I
don't see the point because A4 is not
even a threat
so this question should be asked again
Rook takes D1 Rook takes one Knight
takes E5
perhaps Magnus would just take back and
plant a rook on D7 at the end of the
line and say that he's got good control
but it doesn't look very simple I think
that black would have chances there but
Benjamin the bar is all the way up in
madness's favor
yeah this looks great for Magnus and
takes in case Rook takes D1 you could
also get the bishop take with the Rook
Jan goes Bishop f8 but this will always
leave him with very weak dark swears
mainly straight on d8 and I mean maybe
like 95 now oh
that's a Crusher because now F7 is
hanging directly you can't take this
bishop that looks free on H6 because
Queen takes F7 Queen takes H7 is a
direct Checkmate and if they move that
Queen E7 to save your Bishop Bishop
takes f8 that's gonna hurt oh goodness
you just have no space for your pieces
and E6 is loose
Robert I think this one is just over if
you go queenie7 Magnus just takes and
after Queen takes Bishop takes E6 you
cannot take it so there's queen of fate
and Knight E6 and hear the same thing
Bishop 7 96 in the game is over it's
completely done an extra exchange for
Magnus uh he looks bored with this one
and Jan has had enough Magnus wins he is
now up by three points once more
Benjamin those are the type of games we
were talking about Kyan cannot afford
those little slips that turns the
position from okay to really bad
yeah I am shocked that he did not
recapture with the H1 understand that he
was worried about getting checkmated
along the H file but taken with the
Apple always leaves him with a weak Pawn
on D6 and Magnus took full advantage of
that
bad news foreign fans out there and if
you're a fan of his in the 2021 world
champion match against Magnus you'll
recognize the opening here it's a
Spanish white could take on B5 now and
open up the a file for his Rook go
Knight C3 Knight D5 bedroom I feel like
we've been seeing a lot of this in the
speeches championship
Knight C3 pre-moved oh my goodness and I
wonder what's gonna happen here because
Magnus he's probably too much of a
competitor to even ask for a draw but
sometimes when people Mouse slip right
they draw his offer just to get to the
next game uh but I think Magnus he
doesn't even want one he's so disgusted
with himself I think we should go back
let's show an instant replay of what
happened there because suddenly Magnus
is down two pawns and might just lose
this but if we can go back in time
Benjamin I think it's important to show
everybody where that Mouse Club happened
yeah so here John took on b5n instead of
recapturing Magnus my slip of course he
wanted to play pontex B5 but he played
the move A5 but lucky for him John had
Knight C3 pre-moves otherwise of course
he would have taken the Knight on C6 so
Knight C3 Jan still has a great position
as now he's up two pawns but there's
still work to be done and maybe at the
back of his mind young could be thinking
like hey I could have already won this
game
I could have taken the Knight but I feel
like if you win like that it feels even
worse but now it seems like a more
legitimate fight even though we'll
always have an asterisk because of a
mouse slip so the Knight comes back to
D7 it's gonna slip around to the B6
Square Hit The Rook hit the bishop I
don't feel like this is as easy as one
would think
no there's still work to be done for for
John is he's obviously got a great
position up to pawns I mean really a
dream come true in the real low pass I
like what he's doing though with this
move 94 he wants to go C3 afterwards and
trap this Knight and B4
okay so Magnus you know he looks like
he's reeling Jan is making it look easy
C3 is a great move next and if black has
to play D5 well now you definitely can't
play D5 to 5 tonight
C3 F takes E4 so all right Magnus is
making this messy
right so let's see so C3 pontics E4 you
can go Knight D2 but then then I can
jump into D3 so Magna is doing a great
job complicating this game
I don't know it's not over yet this
vanity 4 is a little bit off
so let's see what John will do here
maybe he'll play
C3 F takes E4 Knight takes E5 because
you're gonna lose that F3 Knight anyway
so you might as well steal that Central
Pawn not allow a black pawn to take on
your dad and F3 and that seems to be the
simplest uh he goes even Knight back to
E1
all right this also still looks crazy
for young but no Magnus can go for like
Bishop 5 followed by Queen E8 the G6 and
again he's still in this game he is down
two pawns but white has this cluster of
Pawns on the queen side that are
difficult to set emotion
I like the plant for black that you just
mentioned the bishop F5 Queen E8 Queen
G6 all that stuff I think it's Black's
only chance considering you are
down a couple pawns and the Knight on A4
is stuck over there and it will take a
while to play B3 Knight B2 it goes so he
goes B4 he's even more direct I like it
but Bishop F5 Queen G6 to follow
Benjamin's the only chance that black
ass with Bishop E4 I'd go for checkmate
and there he goes Queen E5 downbeat
maybe just King to H7 and if you think
on C5 there might be Queen G6 Bishop
takes H3 is a threat but even more
important Bishop to E4 attacking the
queen and the pawn on G2 so this one is
not over just yet Robert
unbelievable if yon doesn't win a game
where Magnus Mouse slipped on what move
is that move like 10 and then doesn't
win up a couple pawns he will be beside
himself you need to win this game if
you're young to Palm machine but Magnus
refuses to lose
I actually think this is a really
difficult position
it's already really tricky I mean again
if they go on C5 there's Queen G6
I don't know it's yeah I'll be tilted
out of my mind if I would not win this
game if I was young maybe there's still
Queen F3 to meet Bishop B4 with Queen G3
let's see what he's gonna go for he
takes his exactly
yes is he gonna go for it he's gone for
it he has to at this point there's a
Checkmate on G2 thread so he's taking
this bishop and the eval bar approves so
young the Palm she with great awareness
I think now he brings his Knight to B6
he protects his C4 Pawn the Knight can
slide even to D5
oh wait
yeah he's just pushing the seat boy
gives up the e-bomb for the seatbel what
do you make of this
yeah I love it for y'all Magnus it goes
Rook V6 let's go Rook T6 and try and
Checkmate over here so rookie four
attacking the queen nice low to move I
guess the queen has to go to like D3 to
go through this spawn it looks great for
you on this everything is defended he's
got these passers but still some work to
be done
so can he play C6 and C7 that's my first
question I know the B5 pod is hanging
but that c Pawn gets up the board very
quickly another option is just to play
C4 yourself but that does keep your Rook
away from the King side like Rook to G6
does seem a little worrisome
yeah and I would be quite reluctant to
go see C4 as you said it allows Rook to
G6 followed by Queen E4 so Rook B4 I
like this one much better The Rook can
always keep an eye on the king side it
does hang the policy three but I think
Robert he just wants to go Rook have to
be one defend everything and then go C6
at the right moment how often do you see
two minor pieces and three pawns for a
queen it's a material imbalance that I
am not accustomed to but those past
pawns are not just on the second reg
they're mobilized they're ready to
become a queen and so I'm with you it
looks very very strong here for white he
goes Rook to B1 he's just once he ever
did together he can play Rook to C1 Pawn
to C6 Pawn to C7 this looks very
difficult to deal with
for a rook G6 a tricky little move
though by Magnus he still wants to go
for the city of Queen E3 and queen E4
and properties one is not over yet if
the queen lands on e4 it will be
uncomfortable to deal with the Checkmate
thread so I love the move Rose before
Beyond great decision making from taking
away critical squares from Black's
pieces and c67 is not going anywhere he
is B5 protected he's got a rook behind
the past sea Pawn the Knight is defended
by the bishop on E3 this is a good try
from Magnus hitting both Rooks but now
the Rooks recorded C6 at long last that
has to be next on the agenda
exactly though C6 is definitely a threat
followed by C7 magnus's clock is
thinking he's done at 18 seconds Robert
I don't see how he's stopping him from
marching up the board here
he's not the pawn is going forward and I
think the Magnus he's pretty much
resigned because he feels like he has no
way to defend he's down to five seconds
needs to find a move here is he's gonna
lose on time kit can you go queen bee
through to take him B5 C7 and then give
up this rook and yawn won on time I I
don't know Magnus I think could have
kept this game going a little bit longer
by taking here taking the Knight and I
guess
well anyway we're off to another game I
I think he just assumed that it was
going to be a loss no matter what and
it's hard to even play when you Mouse
slip so now Magnus has to avoid any kind
of tilting he's up two points so he's
still doing well in the match but it
feels really bad to play A5 instead of
A6 B5
right but it was impressive that he did
find a way to keep the game going John
had to find a queen sacrifice to keep
his Advantage but to his credit he did
and he never let his Advantage go
no he did not Beyond the Palm sheet now
within 2.7 to five I I'm seeing another
alipin Sicilian I'm happy about it my
childhood this feels like it was all
worth it just to see an alapin Sicilian
and a speed test championship match
between these two but you look at this
opening white has an extra Pawn on the
queen side black has an extra Pawn in
the center and that's the dynamic that's
something that you need to watch out for
in an end game where white pushes up B4
and C5 but in the middle game the E6
Pawn that's a very useful Pawn to have
in the center
exactly so I like what he's doing here
with A3 and B4 expanding on the queen
side now the bishop has to move back I
suppose the E7 if you go to B6 it can
always be blocked with the move Pawn C5
he goes Bishop to D4 Robert I think he's
not unhappy about this trade but what
about Rook A2 you want to go Rook D2 pin
the bishop and this just seems like a
loss of time
I don't like the move at all it earned a
question mark which I think is deserved
because of Rook A2 Knight takes D4 Queen
takes D4 will trade the Queens off the
board and maybe Jan feels the end game
is perfectly acceptable for him but
Magnus should slide The Rook up and over
to the center and it feels like there's
a huge problem with the pin down the D
file
yeah so Magnus taking his time but I'm
sure rookie 2 is on his radar like he
said The Rook is moving over here I
don't see what Blake is going to do
about it maybe you just have to go
Bishop to B6 but then you've lost
critical time
yeah why not have Retreat it immediately
that's the big question and Rook A2 is
on the board he plays E5 but this looks
like you're gonna lose a pawn directly
instead of Rook d295 there's Knight
takes E5 for example
I don't like the look of this at all
this looks extremely loose for you on
the good thing for him though is that
he's up almost a minute on the clock
rookie two certainly looks very logical
here for Magnus Knight F5 you just go
Knight takes E5 the Knight cannot be
taken as you hang the queen so you're
gonna have to go Queen C7 maybe if I can
then just take on D4
can you actually sacrifice the queen
John just did it in the previous game so
I'm starting to wonder if uh 95 95 we
get a rook and a knight for a queen and
a pawn but white does have a lack of
development and a bunch of loose squares
it's probably not sufficient but maybe
in a Blitz game it can work out
yes we see Knight 65 on the board I am I
really am doubtful that bish65 is going
to work out I think you just have to
keep pieces on the board like Queen C7
or queen E7 it does look really bad
though so I can just take on D4 if black
crew characters with a knight you can
take the queen uh you can take the
Knight
and you will have two minor pieces for
the rook and that is why John takes 25
but now he's down a clean pawn and white
has the bishop pair
the good news the only bit of good news
for black is that the C4 Pawn is a
backwards pawn and white is behind in
development and the clock situation is
no longer one where Yawn is well ahead
so Magnus has great chances over the
board but maybe Jan is counting on the
fact that he has no more weaknesses now
that he's dropped a pawn
but Magnus plays this so precisely he
moved his side into the game with 92 to
F3 kicking that Queen away and Robert
what about a move like Bishop 4 here in
case you take the bishop you can take on
d8 and if you take on D3 you take the
queen and I think all of it works out
brilliantly but it goes Queen C2
I love Bishop F4 I was taking advantage
of taxes actually earned was that a
blunder symbol there for Queen to C2 and
Knight D6 also an inaccuracy a Miss by a
yon so both players are on shaky grounds
but he's going after C4 Bishop F5 is a
secondary threat white might have to
play I'm like Rook oh right Rook D4
might hang the B5 Pawn as you're
pointing out so what does Men's do here
I don't know it's a good question a lot
of threats here all of a sudden from
yawn we see Magnus dropping below a
minute it's this one is not over just
yet maybe Robert you can play C5 other
than there's Bishop five
whoa because the C pod is pinned to the
queen down on C2 so Bishop F5 looks like
a good try and you can see yeah I'm
thinking here he's like something feels
available to Black there's going to be a
tactic and he plays Bishop to F5
and queen C8 by John okay Roxy one
okay so if you take the Rook I think
white just recaptures and you have to go
back to the pass of the eight Square
sorry E8 Square which looks terrible
maybe maybe you like black can take here
you can take on d8 black recaptures but
then your queen is hanging oh that's
actually a really important point and if
you can steal that pawn no longer does
white have an opposing passer up the
queen side so a lot of us will be
tempted to take on D3 Gulp and exchange
and Jan goes for that but you actually
see the evaluation bar go even higher
for white because look at how passive
black he has a knight E5 he doesn't even
take the pawn back he wants to take with
the Knight Hit The Rook on 97 check Fort
Benjamin this is getting out of hand for
Yonder bomb machine
this is looking ugly he's of the
exchange but all of his pieces are are
passive only this nine and F6 is not on
the back rank like you said Magnus wants
to take here and take the Rook also a
third and a fork over here so maybe Jan
has to move the queen preemptively but I
don't know I mean it looks very bad also
Magnus has this majority on the queen
side this looks great
looks like a tough position for Yan who
won the previous game he brings his
Knight up to D5 and now Knight C6 with
Knight F4 is with a knight E7 check
winning that Queen
and also Robert White can pick up the
spawn on H7 although not anymore the
bishop on F4 is under attack so I assume
at some moment you move it maybe to G3
and again it's super difficult for black
to to make an active move here but
there's some tricks because Knight takes
d8 my backfire Queen takes C2 and no
matter what you take with blackified
Knight takes F4 next and there's even
either a attack on the bishop on D3 or a
fork on E2 so it does feel like maybe
there's some tricks here that keep young
look at this he goes Rook
you take an H7 and black has two knights
but the end game is completely lost
that's why it's going to pick up this a
pawn and we'll get two connected passers
on the queen side that doesn't deserve
one exclamation point it deserves two
and a half that was such a nice
realization by Magnus Carlsen that two
my pieces are more than a rook in a pawn
but the end game would have been winning
for white and now we see a beautiful
position where yes Magnus is one Pawn
ahead but after the light comes back to
C6 it's about to be a second when A7
Falls
John is still fighting though he's
jumping around his Knights but I don't
think they create any meaningful threats
managers goes push to C4 maybe now Rook
D7 are taking F7 and taking A7 this one
looks over
can you just grab this A7 Pawn he goes
Rook D7 first A7 is falling and as long
as you fall from Knight D2 check he
avoided that this should be a clean
victory for Magnus Carlson
yeah H4 he just pushed the Knight back
and here goes to people and so young
wisely resigns he keeps time on the
match clock this one is over so let's
see what he can do with white pieces
well hopefully for him he's another win
but he will not be so lucky to see
Magnus Mouse I think Magnus he's going
to be a little bit more careful with his
clicks this time around and we have
another Spanish so we might see the same
exact position but without a piece
dropping on B5
exactly yeah I think it would be wise
for Magnus to just pre-move the move
Pawn xb5 to make sure that he can on my
slip we see the move Bishop B7 here a
different anti-marshall with uh D3 and
D6 the quiet play here as well black is
currently having the positional threat
Knight A5 which would trap the bishop
for the Knight now you can go 95 anyway
followed by bonus E5 to gain space on
Queen side
it's a natural plant it looks good for
black to do just that he instead plays
the quiet H6 no Bishop G5 no taking over
the D5 Square we're seeing some
rerouting they played a number of very
quiet openings Benjamin
exactly and now you go to C5 expanding
on the queen side yarn going Pawn to D4
main is taking once is he gonna take
twice yes he does black has this
isolated Pawn on D6 but the pawn E4 is
under a lot of pressure and black gets
pretty good piece of activity here so
Black's generally doing fine
it's what we've been talking about
whenever you even isolated Pawn you've
opened files in the adjacent lines the
e-file and the C file are in Black's
favor staring at the E4 Pawn The Rook
stands all the way down the bishop on C2
the Knight for black and jump into C4
and at some moment black can consider
the move D6 to D5 to get rid of your
isolated pawn and blast open the center
and the dark squares for that Bishop run
f8
right but I love this move B3 by Young
he's stopping the knife from jumping to
C4 which is why the Knight jumps back to
C6 and now he goes Bishop to B2 uh
comfortably developing his bishop and it
will always have an eye on the Knight on
F6 so black cannot move their queen as
then white can take and damage black
spawn structure on the king side
okay we see G6 played by Magnus a lot of
us would be too afraid to make that move
opening up the dark squares but he's
gonna compete for the diagonal with
Bishop to G7 in the near future and
meanwhile Jan plus B4 A4 at some point
could be on the docket I think the black
is completely fine right now
yeah Bishop G7 so let's see I guess A4
now his ID was actually to go Bishop to
B3 but Robert can black take on e4 I
suppose he's looking at some stuff
connected with Bishop takes F7 and queen
of three down the line but it doesn't
work
it's a big question right now that
Magnus is working to figure out he has
Knight E4 it does look like you can get
away with this as Bishop takes F7 won't
be able to play with check because the
bishop is loose on D4 these are actually
some high level tactics and so for Jan
he may have overlooked that detail
that'll have to throw in Bishop takes G7
kick takes G7 and I'm not sure that he
gets away with all this
yeah Robert what he might have missed is
that after Knight takes C4 let's say you
take everything and then at the end you
give a check on D4 black and gold queen
of six and at the end of all of the
variations there will always be a rook
hanging on A1 and now yon has passed the
thing but it's a little bit too late
it's now he's down a pawn I don't think
you drew enough arrows on that board so
maybe let's add a few because that is
really the tactics that you have to look
out for in true Hikaru Nakamura style
take six takes with all the arrows but
it is important that actually after the
series of exchanges The Rook on A1 is
loose there so white can't pick up the
piece on e4 and if you can't do this
Benjamin then that means the whole line
is bad for white is there another move
that he can play besides trading
everything off
I don't see it I think in every
variation it's going to be a problem
that The Rook on A1 is hanging so maybe
you have to play like Queen D3 or queen
F3 but I can just play D5 and again
you're down a very clean Pawn so yeah
Jan is thinking now but he should have
thought on the last move
it's one of those impulsive decisions
where you miss a tactic in the center
and we are seeing Magnus go for this all
of these trades are happening and
instead of a swap on G7 first queen to
D2 he's just gonna find this down a pawn
so Benjamin great start to this game for
Magnus
yeah this is not looking like a whole
lot of fun for a young Magnus can just
go Queen G5 force of Queen trade going
into an end game up a pawn I mean one
more can you ask for with the black
pieces again like here there's less
arrows so again because it takes takes
in Queen E4 the rose queen of six and if
you take there's Queen takes A1
yeah you are responding to chat chat are
you excited for this match and the match
later today nihal sarin against Maxine
versus so do not go anywhere even when
this match ends we still have so much
chess to be played and well Benjamin I
think right now the chess in this game
is all Magnus he's up a d-pawn it's a
healthy Pawn it's can be protected with
move like Rook C6 uh Rook to d8 as well
how does Magnus turn this from a slight
plus into a win that's the big question
I have
yeah let's see how he will do it Rook C6
looks like a nice move you can also go
Bishop 2c2 attacking The Rook attacking
the bishop on B3 it looks like white has
to trade on C2 black recaptures you can
take on G7 and take on D6 but black
plays Rook takes A2 and there we see
them going down that line black takes an
A2 and defends upon E6 so we see yon
playing Pawn A4 first
I love moves like that where you're
gonna lose the pawn to please take me on
A4 The Rook will go take the D6 pawn and
take the A6 Pawn after that and he's
liquidating so I do think that was a
good decision from Beyond the Palm
machine and it two results black either
wins this game or yawn defends
accurately and what he does Rook A1
instead of taking D6 what do you make of
that
record one gray move by Young Rook C6 by
Magnus and now he's probably gonna move
his King up Magnus still has good
chances to win but I think yonder did a
very good job over the last couple of
moves he is now he now has serious uh
chance to hold this one
you look at the position oh G4 was given
a question mark the King goes to E6
please take me on G5 says Magnus because
then D5 happens that Rook is shut out
and almost trapped
yeah no that was not a good decision G5
is completely trapped he goes H4 trying
to create a passer on the king side but
I think it's all going to be a little
bit too slow Magnus can take him before
but he's got six seconds oh time
wait did he slip again
why would you be Rook B5 there instead
of Rook takes B4 that was a free Pawn
maybe he wants to go D4 and trade up the
Rooks that would be ingenious if D4 is a
winning uh King and Pawn in game but he
instead goes kf6 to the outside pass
Pawn we've talked about this in previous
games that if you did trade Rooks white
would have his H5 push the right way one
second Robert he's just lost 20 Tempe
like what does he do why did he not take
on B4 to look completely winning not as
well should just be a draw it looks like
an easy draw three on two on one side a
pass Pawn on the other but the Rook
stands behind the pass Pawn Benjamin
that was weird we're not used to seeing
Magnus spend so much time like that in
positions with great winning chances
exactly yeah now I guess he's just gonna
wait he lost he lost the time he lost
some time and look at John's face he's
in disbelief and Magnus is furious what
was he thinking about
I don't know what happened I don't
here's the thing Robert maybe he wanted
to play Rook A1 to H1 but the move is so
far across the board that it took him
too long to make the move that's very
possible and whatever it was Magnus is
not a happy camper he leaves he goes to
take a break because is the Midway point
of the three plus one but Benjamin we
can't beat around this big moment here
where Janda palmshi has been the
recipient of a mouse slip and then a win
on time I mean what is going on with
Magnus
what an absolute chakra Magnus is still
very well in control of this match but
Jana's in it he's only down two points
but Magnus should have won that game if
he wins the game he goes up four points
and I think the match is practically
over but now there's still a chance
John the Palm she cuts that deficit he
is really doing a good job to keep this
match competitive and we want to shout
out not just this match but what time of
the year it is because we all love
September we get the nicer weather it's
not as hot but it's also subtember to
the end of this month claim up to 30 off
all new Subs on Twitch subscribers gain
access to exclusive break time content
during broadcast unlock new emotes with
Danny's various Expressions mittens and
even Magnus and nepo and score an ad
free experience on chess.com don't miss
out on the deals this September
subscribe now we will be back for more
from the speeches Championship presented
by coinbase this is Magus Carlson versus
John the Palm Street see you in a few
thank you
[Music]
foreign
why did you on passant bro I swear to
god Amazon should be enforced all my
friends watching and this day is taking
forever play faster if I could move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb
I should be able to flag him no matter
how many times I repeat moves 1400 years
and it's the same game every
time you know what it's time for some
updates I'm tired of this I'm I'm doing
it stalemate is now a win for the player
who gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen trout pawns can
move backwards why is that and never not
been a rule pawns come backwards now
every piece should be allowed to on
passant what that's not even possible
how ship it dunzo update enter
why is an ending there's just two kings
on the board what is this Purgatory this
is so awesome what we're doing
[Music]
here they won
wait what Checkmate do I have to get to
move from now on C4 actually explodes
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update take down
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
smearches is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hairs start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which we charge after five moves
you may cast your spare whenever you
wish before making a regular chest move
jump is a spare cash to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cast
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place
to defeat your opponent
come see what supercell and chess.com
have cooked up in our new variant spell
chess dropping on September 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
Magnus Carlsen needs no introduction
he's a player who's appeared to the
finals sometimes seems guaranteed but he
hasn't always made it to the speeches
Championship Finals when he has
participated in the event Benjamin we
know that he's had these head-to-head
matchups against Hikaru Nakamura he lost
in 2022 in the finals but before that he
was actually upset before he could
actually reach the final match
yeah in 2020 he lost the mvl in the
semifinals that was quite a surprise but
we see in 2016 and 2017 he beat
hikarnakamura quite convincingly in 2017
actually by a 10 point margin but it
seems like Hikaru has managed to flip
the script
kikaru has done so well in this SCC he
is five-time reigning champion and
Magnus Carlsen would like to take that
title from Nakamura but he first has to
get through yonda palmchi who suddenly
is only one point away Benjamin it's
been surprising there's been a mouse
slip there's been a loss on time Yanda
Palm she doesn't care how he gets it
done as long as the wins Stack Up
exactly and we are off to another game
we again see yon going back to the path
of Defense but yeah Magnus has been in
full control but yeah some unfortunate
losses we saw like you said that that
blunder also at that time they're lost
on time I I don't know what happened
there Robert again like do you think he
he just forgot about the club for a
second
I think maybe your point was a good one
that he looked to bring that Rook all
the way across the board and it's a
distant move hard to get off in time
when you only have a couple seconds but
no matter what the reason was maybe
we'll have a chance to ask Magnus uh the
match is getting closer instead of Jan
spiraling out of control he is now
keeping this match close he is only down
by a couple games two game margin so
it's going to be a tougher fight than
Magnus would have hoped for
right so we should remove 982 defending
the Knight on F3 perhaps now moved like
rookie eight by Young I like this one
now you can recapture the king maybe
they'll move the king over to d8 so then
he can bring this rook and h8 into game
he goes Knight takes E8 it looks a
little bit passive at first glance but
he can always rewrite this now with
let's say 97 and then trade out the
Bishops with Bishop F5
and that Rook on A1 if it were already
on E1 we'd be talking about an advantage
for white because your first the open
file but Magnus expands on the queen
size my Rook may be into starting square
but I can develop it from where it sits
let's push pawns up the board A4 Knight
B3 and so on this is a very Magnus style
position
exactly you slowly patrolling proven but
I also really like how yam is rerouting
his pieces he goes Knight to E7 now he
can go Bishop F5 or king of seven move
up his King his Rook can potentially
come into the game and Magnus is gaining
space over here on the queen side but I
don't really see what he's achieved just
yet
does he want the bishop pair like d
takes C4 Knight takes C4 the bishop on
D6 it doesn't really have too many
squares to go to you don't want to go up
to B4 The Rook will go to B1 and kick it
around some more but if you take on D6
and the Knight takes back black is fully
developed with no real weaknesses that I
can see
right and that is why John goes Bishop
B6 he does not mind the trade
maintenance now goes pushed A3 but I
think Jana's doing absolutely fine here
like you said Magnus has the best repair
but his isolated Pawn on D4 deprives him
of an advantage so Rook D7 nice way on
defending the Palm on C7 and white needs
to be careful because Knight coming to
D5 that Knight protects C7 it also could
jump to F4 the B5 Pawn it's Advanced is
looking pretty good but it can also be
vulnerable as maybe at some point black
can team up against it I think all the
blacks pieces are perfect squares
a 95 nice move here by John he wants to
another four attack that Bishop perhaps
the bishop will have to move back to F1
but he can also the 995 also defends
upon on C7 so maintenance drops the
bishop back to F1 preemptively and let's
see what John is going to do here he
should be doing 594 perhaps he wants to
go to C3
I think Jan wants to win this game the
way his Knights are hopping up the board
why not the white pawns they push
forward but they're not queening anytime
soon and they can be weaknesses as now
the pawns are not in contact with one
another and those Knights are very jumpy
and Robert are we going to see a draw
here Bishop D3 by Magnus 96 this is an
invitation to repetition I mean yum of
course either player could deviate here
with uh with another move
it would be such a strange draw but
Magnus he should realize that right now
he's no better that his isolated Pawn is
a long-term weakness that it's not clear
how he would play for a win he pushes
forward with A6
engine that's a move that can backfire
because now you have the cemented Pawn
structure unless that Knight goes say
like E1 C2 B4 C6 something like that I
don't know how it ever will get to C6 I
feel like this static Pawn structure
should favor Black
yeah I'm starting to like Young's
position more and more we see him
expanding here on the king side King
each to a clever move by Magnus so he
can go G3 and opponent H3 will not be
hanging he now goes H4 Jan has to go G4
to keep his Pawn structure intact
kicking the Knight away but this F4
square has been weakened and Magnus will
be looking to take advantage of this
maybe 91 to G2 and potentially not a
four of this Knight moves
and look at this Knight F5 the Knight
was kicked away from defending the D4
Pawn so John says why not let me go
after that very Pawn in the center and I
think Knight C2 is a little bit
worrisome for young because you want to
move your knight from D5 and he does
that but at some point Knight B4 the C6
you have to be very very careful with
your A7 Pawn if that's Pawn's lost white
has a very Advanced passer
yeah so we've got a pretty interesting
position here he goes Bishop to D5 white
cannot play Knight before just yet like
you said it would hang the pawn on D4
okay now 93 Bishop three I like this
bishop here on F3 it's nicely cemented
here by these spawns at some point Jan
can consider taking but Robert look at
the clock he's way up on time
continues to be a speed demon C6 here
looks like a very good move inside my
eyes a bc6 knight takes C6 and that pawn
A6 is a future Target the b-pod is
sprung free the D4 Pawn is loose the
white king is in trouble and C5 a very
similar idea I think that b takes E6 is
likely and Jan he has the upper hand
right exactly you've taken on C6 so he's
going to recapture with the Knight I
like what John is doing here he's
playing quickly and confidently and
what's great for him is that he's
actually uh playing Magnus a little bit
in these end Games The Pawn on the first
week main is there Focus Knight C2 I
think a correct decision to not allow
this Knight to jump into C6 as it would
put massive pressure on the wide
position also keep in mind the Deep on
for the moment of spin is it would hang
the bishop on D3 so let's see how Jan
will tighten the screws here
he brings his King up in the center
white does the same I like the choice
for both of them where's progress how
does either side move forward is it F5
F4 for black just trying to create a
secondary weakness in the position
wait what is Pawn 64. now maintenance
can recapture with a knight and you can
take enough stream black is talking with
all of these weaknesses did you see Jan
he was very upset with himself he
chastised himself he completely
overlooked Knight takes D4 grabbing this
bishop on F3
yeah no Magnus takes another three he
recaptures but look at this Knight D4
shutting the Rook out Magnus now wants
to go kingy two and Robert what has
happened John was in the driver's seat
he was putting a bit of pressure now all
of a sudden it looks like he might just
be lost king of two is coming after Rook
moves there's Rook C7 and I don't see
how you're keeping this together one
tiny oversight loses you on the game I
mean he must be in a losing position
Magus about 30 seconds himself we saw
him lose on time that was shocking it's
not gonna happen again
King D3 his second F2 Pawn but you don't
really care about that it's very
difficult for black to create a password
on the king side rookie three I guess
you just go King up to C4 or here or the
C2 everything looks winning because
kingy four the spawning A7 is going to
drop Robert and that should be the game
the Knight doesn't even have any good
moves you gotta go Knight G8 but there
might even some ideas to Checkmate the
black king not right now but Knight F5
Rook G7 would be a mating net if not for
Rook A4 check but just take A7 uh you're
easily winning as black is tied down
this is so unfortunate for John again
like he has to avoid these blunders he
goes okay one now why can I take a
search for q1 so many takes the A7 pawn
and Rook D7 search position paralyzing
the Knight as they can no longer go to
D6
and he's gonna bring his Knight in A7
next and I think the very best for black
is down a full piece and he's not even
getting the B5 Pawn
no this is over Magnus upper full piece
young presses the resign button but what
an unfortunate loss he he should not
have lost this one no I mean he just
completely overlooked and Knight takes
D4 was allowed it was a check it was
able to take that Bishop on F3 and that
was a really bad turn of events for Yan
Who's down by three points so Benjamin
we keep talking about it if Magnus is
gonna gift you points you can't gift
them back and that's what Jan just did
and he is now in some trouble
exactly like you're gonna be a played in
some games that can happen but you
shouldn't give him points like by making
blunders losing out of the opening you
gotta try to play as tight as possible
we see John here playing with white
pieces I like what he's doing going for
Russell limo man is going for the setup
with uh the pawns on the queen side and
Bishop D6 so let's see if young can put
some pressure here with the white pieces
but yeah that was such a costly throw if
he had won that game it would have been
back to two points but now the margin is
three again and three it's not
insurmountable but at some point you
know you you have to make a comeback
and Magnus is so good in bullet chest
that you can't even count on that you
know some players you play against them
you think it's going to be a topsy-turvy
final stretch we did see Wesley so take
down all the reason and bullet that was
surprising to the masses so it is
possible and I think Hikaru spoke on
that saying that nobody would have given
Wesley a chance to beat other resident
bullet he was able to make it even they
went into an Armageddon game which
Wesley won so John still has chances
even if we get to bullet and he's down
by a couple games but he can't afford to
keep losing he cannot allow the lead to
balloon to save four or five points
no for sure I think what's up what
people sometimes forget in the bullet
portion is that it's one plus one if it
would be one plus zero I think Ali Reza
would be a big big favorite against uh
Wesley but with the one second increment
that makes all the difference it's still
normal chess it's still very similar to
three plus one there will not be you
know flagging things of that nature and
that is why Wesley uh managed to beat
alireza I like what John is doing here
again he's playing quickly and I think
he's preparing a D4 or B4 push at some
point
why not open up that dark Square Bishop
uh if the king castles then it's hard to
move that C5 Pawn as The Rook will be
loose at the end of the line so D4 does
seem to be a threat and Magnus he's
spending his time yawn up about a minute
on the clock this feels like a game
where he has chances once again
right but what about the small Bishop G4
here Robert you threaten to take an F3
and double bytes pawns and now the
Knight and F3 is finished you put this
working on I don't see a good way to get
out of it in case of Queen E2 black is
Knight G5 so that looks pretty
unpleasant for young perhaps he should
have played H3 on one of the last couple
of moves
and whoa magnifies the castle instead we
do see default
the position was very close and now
suddenly it's blasting open the night at
C4 is under attack the C5 Pawn is under
attack The Rook on f8 is behind that C5
pawn and we are seeing some trades here
but beef no B4 is not going to be
available to Black is it
wait I am quite surprised by by what
John just did why did he trade on B5 he
could have also just played 93 right
away I guess the difference is is that
now B4 is not a move as you take and the
C Pawn will be pinned and Magnus takes
on D4 he's sacking in a change but look
at this Robert if you recapture take on
the C2 and take a B3 and you not only at
the bishop air but you also have two
outside passers this looks great for
Magnus
with that Bishop on f8 supporting them
from afar the A4 B for A3 you take this
Knight on C2 and the bishop on f8 is
actually doing a great job of Defending
those passers so this looks tragic for
Yan and perhaps you know you think about
it you have a rook for just one minor
piece and one Pawn you think you're
ahead but it's not just about the point
value it's about how strong these pawns
are and while A4 got a question mark I
think that we can all tell that white is
definitely in trouble but Benjamin he
allowed D5 maybe that's why A4 was not
the best move
yeah perhaps he had to move like Bishop
to H6 attacking The Rook of The Rook
booster hang the Knight now we see
Magnus going F5 okay he's playing pretty
actively but he's also loosening up his
own position 92 nice move by Yan he
wants to take the bishop on B3 get rid
of the bishop repair and then the pawns
can become a little bit loose and look
at the clock forward all of a sudden
Janice up a minute so this one is far
from over and Bishop H6 no longer works
as Knight takes B3 and after a takes P3
then Knight to E3 those Double B pawns
are bad news for black you can't allow
white to take this bishop on B3 I don't
think so maybe you should take the
Knight on C2 then you're worried about
the open C file some counter chances for
white
D6 I guess this idea is that in case y
takes and then moves the Knight you can
take the pawn on e4 so let's see what
John is going to do here you can take an
F5 but then black can escape with the
bishop with Bishop takes D5 so Yonkers
Knight E3 first
okay so if
you take on e4 with the pawn then Knight
takes B3 so he goes for this anyway
but is there
ignite D2 somehow coming
all right so we see Bishop before by
Magnus attacking The Rook where do you
go with the Rook wherever you go you're
gonna get forked if you go to F1 there's
a fork on D2 if you go to C1 there's
Knight C3 followed by Knight E2 so this
looks quite problematic
why is that a question mark I don't see
what you do Rook to C1 for example I
think here you can just play Knight D2
it Rook B2 Bishop A3 and that's game
over
that's game over yeah Magnus is already
up a pawn or so for the exchange or wait
no he's up two pounds so if he wins back
the exchange here he will be up a clean
two pawns this B Pawn will be super
strong so like you said Robert this
almost to be over
it is now and you can see it on Jan's
face he's not very happy and Magnus he's
about to lead by Four Points unless
there is some way to make a draw but I
don't think so you're gonna take on E3
take on D5 it's gonna be two extra pawns
and one's in the center one's a passer
on the queen side and that's just going
to be an easy conversion for Magnus
Carlson
exactly he's just in time with Rook
takes D5 defending upon E5 and on B5
Rook C3 by young plays very quickly but
this one is completely over Rook V8 such
a nice move by Magnus he's giving up the
e-pawn but he's putting the Rook behind
the passer that's where he wanted now he
moves his King up and this game is over
Robert right because the white king will
have to continue going to the queen side
but it doesn't even get there in time
and then the black king even if you were
able to surround the pawn can go back
towards the king side to win the game so
this looks like a prom King C1 The Rook
releases to E8 or A8 and we see a win
for Magnus Carlson from the black side
Benjamin young he's shaking right now
and this could get out of hand if he
doesn't stop the bleeding
yeah all of a sudden it's uh it's a four
point gap that's quite half the episode
break it was only two points I thought
John was still having a very good chance
he also had chances in that black game
in the patron but we saw how he took on
D4 a little too quickly and again he's
just losing games in a necessary Manner
and Magnus is just more consistent
he is indeed and we see the this game it
looks very solid but we have a Sicilian
Defense so it was a night or then it
turns into a dragon-like position and
black has no weaknesses white similarly
doesn't really have any weak he says
that white has more control so what's
Black's plan in a position like this
it's a good question I mean I also
struggle sometimes in these positions
like what is the plan he goes 95 to C4
all right so white can stop though with
B3 but I guess then Queen C7 is annoying
attacking the Knight on C3 so let's see
how Magnus is going to deal with this he
can also allow Knight C4 it's really not
a big deal but then black gets The Rook
to C4 he can double and even triple on a
C4 so I guess that's what John is going
for right here
yeah Knight C4 does get black Bishop
hair but once you swap there's also
these E5 tactics that you have to be
worried about so yanate puts his Bishop
on C6 but then the question is why is
the Knight on E5 but the Knight doesn't
seem like it's really doing all that
much there if it can't jump forward
anymore
exactly F3 nice move by Magnus
solidifying the pawn E4 now Magnus wants
to go A5 create a clamp on the queen
side as Bishop can always slide into B6
at the right moment and look at this
he's played F4 and he's giving Yan a
bunch of weaknesses on the king's head
all of a sudden this looks really good
for white
yeah maybe the claim is that there's
some counter play if you go after the H5
pawn it takes a bit of time it's kind of
got some spasky Fisher Vibes to it but
the Knight came back to D4 so quickly
going after the bishop Knight F5 going
after the other Bishop looks very
worrisome for the black king
not a big fan of this position for young
I mean neither Knight C5 was played a
tanked upon D4 so Magnus streets on C6
and now plays E5 taking advantage of the
pin along the default you cannot take
that pawn
at some point maybe Magnus can take
Queen C8 maybe now 95 threatening a
deadly Fork which is why you don't plays
rookie eight
wow this is hanging on by a thread for
you on the Palm Street but his position
even though his double I said H bonds
look bad I think he has good activity
the queen of Rook on the C file at some
point you have to watch out for your C2
Pawn being loose you can't push the C
Pawn because Knight B3 tactics
um if you take on D6 the bishop on G7 is
now out in the open suddenly I believe a
little bit more in Jan's position
exactly the screen can also slide into
F5 defending the the king's head a
little bit minus does not have a
knockout here in case he takes on D6
John should not or maybe he can even
recapture with the rokus Knight 67
there's Rook takes and at the end of it
all the bishop only three is hanging so
I don't know what Magnus to do here and
look at the clock forward all of a
sudden he's down a minute
and this makes sense this time
management for Yawn is paying off it's a
complicated position I think that black
could be better in a few turns the white
king even though it looks safe some of
those dark squares in front of it are
very loose and so Magnus takes the
Knight on C5 and I would take with the
Rook on C5 because if you took with the
pawn then the bish1 G7 was locked in now
that Bishop it slices across the
diagonal and has some play
right so you take some of these things
and forces John to recapture the pawn
Jana is a very ugly structure here he's
got these isolated pawns all over the
board but his Rook is active his Queen
is active his Bishop is open as well so
he might not be doing too bad here
rookie one nice move by Magnus so
reinforcing the threat of 97 check
and giving up the B2 Pawn but he doesn't
care about that part maybe he does the
way he just put his hand up he's maybe
recognizing that Bishop takes B2 is a
possibility because the Rook on A1 is
under attack and after Rook to B1
is there some kind of
swap on E1 and Bishop C3 I'm not really
sure there
maybe no Bishop C3 right away loses due
to Rook 68 and Knight takes C3 so I
wonder what exactly John could do there
maybe you can take on C2 instead of them
no they're protecting C8 again I don't
know he plays King hm but that looks
really passive now you just hand Magnus
a better position
and it's clear Bishop takes B2 was
available both by magnus's Body Language
and the question mark given to King h8
not an easy move to play to remove your
only defender of your king to the other
side of the board but Magnus Carlsen
trades Rooks now puts his Pawn on C3 and
strategically Benjamin I think we can
say that white is winning strategically
but there are some holes in White's King
side on the dark squares and it's not
easy to break through when you have to
worry about your own King
exactly because Queen D3 slowly but
surely improving the position however
now he can no longer go Rook T1 Quincy 6
and Knight E3 yawns pieces are becoming
a vimorator but overall it looks great
for Magnus black is this ugly Pawn
structure with isolated Pawns in the
center and on the king's side this
Knight can always move that five which
is why young played queen of D7 that
being said though it's not that easy to
bring this broken as if you go rookie
One You're Gonna hang this a pawn
and that's why I went A5 but it gave
black the B5 Square versus before these
before and you see Magnus he recognized
it as soon as he played the move he was
like what am I thinking
wait does one could completely turn
around all of a sudden Jonas up upon
these pawns are on darfurt Queen E6 nice
move off in the trade of Queens Magnus
doesn't mind the trade of Queens but he
wants to trade on the his terms Bishop
C3 I guess tanks is not good because of
Bishop D4 oh that's a nasty looking pin
white maybe hanging on by a thread here
and look at the clock by the way Madness
down to 15 seconds to Jan's minute Plus
yo what do you do here what do you do
again you don't want to trade you place
F5 okay John can trade he can also just
move the queen as now the dark shares
have been weakened even more I would go
Queen E7 defend all your pawns the B4
Pawn is loose they're pins the queen H4
check is available to go after that B4
Pawn he plays Queen F6 but why would you
give up the B7 Pawn
what was that he gives a B7 and A6
Magnus goes king of three I don't know
what Jonah's line here Magnus seems to
be completely fine
and kf3 maybe not the most precise but
in time travel looks like a good move
and if you take on E3 King takes E3 that
looks like we should be heading towards
drawville because the white king will
probably see tons of checks and not be
able to successfully Escape
yeah but I can pick up some pawns maybe
the pawn in the fight but white should
always have sufficient counter play as
they're gonna get a passer on the queen
side so I don't think there's anything
more here than a draw for young I mean
slightly disappointing for Magnus he was
in control for most of the game but uh I
think if you're young you might be
kicking yourself as this might have been
an opportunity to close the gap a little
bit Jan went for a win with D5 the
engine didn't love it but he is maybe
just able to force a draw at the stage
with checking on the dark squares but
Magnus he's the only one who can win
this position
that being said wait there's no good
check now so young is King G7 V6 check
D4 wait this is still a three years old
game Yahoo's Pawn is better both are
passed Queenie fans are very nice move
okay okay you hang the power check you
kind of take a D4 so it goes okay all
right there goes A5 there take an A5 and
you're playing for two results now
Sun oh Queen trade because Black's Pawn
structure is bad it's gonna be a sundial
but the king stays in touch with the
queen Benjamin as long as the queen
stays on D5 I have a hard time imagine
white losing this game
creating each other he could have taken
95 as G2 was not hanging because of
Queen six of seven this one should be a
drop because black spawn structure is so
bad
yeah Queen F5 normally up opponent end
game should lead to win but not with
double isolated H pawns like this and
now the queen trade is offered oh good
try though by Yan and now it should be
an easy draw
yeah this one is an easy draw if
blackhead doubled f-pawns it would have
still been been a chance with double H
pawns I think there's nothing you can do
here the king of five the king just
steps back and again if you oh yeah
there's nothing to be done here
if they're double F bonds you would have
the F3 move instead we see a draw Beyond
the Palm machine he had a missed
opportunity once Magnus blundered that
B4 Pawn so both players have not been
fully accurate but this is going to be
our final game before the bullet there
are less than three minutes remaining in
the three plus one so Benjamin I think
for Jana palmchi he needs to find a win
here
exactly we've seen English opening minus
playing the system with Knight F6 and
pawn to H6 B4 I think Giannis following
the game between Prague and Magnus in
the World Cup in the in the finals 94 A4
here by uh by young but yeah yon needs
at least a win here to close down the
Gap a little bit with three points I
still think that Magnus is a heavy heavy
favorite but at least there would be
some chances
he needs to get a victory to cut this to
three he'll just feel better about
himself if he's able to be in that kind
of Striking Distance but Magnus he plays
A6 he develops his rook in starting
Square he wants to open the a file and I
feel like this position it's it's not
one of those tactical melees it's a
situation where both sides are playing
small waiting moves hoping to improve
their position
exactly rookie had a crafty little move
by Magnus he's waiting for Yan to take
us now this will open up the e-file for
his rookie might also consider the move
B4 here I think that is the only reason
why he's supposed to think
because otherwise you just take the
Knight
yeah so what is going on right now uh we
see that Magnus is choosing between
these two but
he plays B4 so he takes the road Let's
Travel by and Jan was surprised
yeah exactly B4 I'm sure that John had
to anticipated this move for Pawn 64
maybe uh okay so Bishop Cafe the bishop
drops back I think black should be doing
quite fine here white is a little bit
more active but this Pawn on A5 is
isolated so Magnus can't try to Target
it later Yawn is preparing to meet C6
with 93 to C4 which looks pretty
reasonable he puts a pressure on D5 and
you further defend the Palm on A5 oh
look at this move Bishop takes F6 Queen
takes F6 Bishop takes E4 is this a pawn
sacrifice or what exactly does black
have in store
the opponent A5 is hanging at the end so
you see yaunting only four but I think
here if you take on D1 and take an E4
black should be doing pretty fine maybe
young can consider the take and go Rook
the eight to freeze black but is there
well is there a way for Blake to crawl
out
that looks scary there may be a rook A4
move to counter pin some of the pieces
and perhaps they're not enough pieces
remaining for white to really have the
upper hand but it does look a little
annoying
yeah so I think that is why Magnus has a
pasta thing it looks quite scary okay he
does take an E4 let's see if Jana's
gonna go for it take an E4 and take on
d8 that being said there's no immediate
threat especially before is not
available and maybe black just has the
time to go let's say F6 king of seven
followed by rookie and then black Zoom
very well strategically with the bishop
error exactly what Magnus goes for so
you spotted it he did as well and now as
you said the king gets out with to F7
the A5 Pawn is a target black has the
bishop pair and after King F7 the next
one could be Rook to E8 just to trade
off those Rooks
an F3 by Young trying to kick the Rook
away from the fourth rank so there's
Bridge before but Magnus does not fall
for it he goes Rook to A4 stopping the
Bishop from coming here and I think he's
doing quite well here Knight C2 you can
trade here and then play King of seven s
words that being said how do you unpin
yourself here in the back rank You're
Gonna Play Bishop E7 and when The Rook
goes to AJ You're Gonna Go Bishop back
to f8 and then shut the door on the rook
in the corner so it's actually quite
straightforward very nicely done by
Magnus King F7 Bishop E7 and The Rook is
flushed out of there
yeah I love that idea Robert I don't see
what John should do in the meantime
right now he has to recapture with one
of his pieces I suppose with the Knight
king of seven is going to come maybe
like Knight B3 but then Bishop B7 The
Rook has to move and Bishop fate and it
looks like Magnus has a very comfortable
Advantage he's got the bishop error
spawn 95 is a little bit weak so it's
looking tough for Jan here
Knight takes A1 to B3 I like that the
best but I don't think it's that good of
a position the bishop pair is just
strong and once that second Bishop
enters the light Square Bishop I feel
like white is going to be on the
defensive and Jan doesn't look very
happy
oh Bishop B7 great to find here by
Magnus The Rook has to move I guess
maybe you have to move it all the way
back but then after Bishop B6 blank is
in full control like I said I mean his
rookie shade you go for Faith Shut
The Rook out the was gonna join
the action and black is uh comfortably
better
and then the question goes to how did
whoa he allowed his Rook to be shut off
back there
that's surprising to me
okay Benjamin this this is bad for white
again like black just play C5 here and
start pushing those Pawns
C5 is a nice move I think what Gianna's
banking on is that in case uh Magnus
goes Bishop B6 then you go in Knight C5
taking advantage or the fact that this
bishop is pinned again as a rook on
eight is hanging there we go Knight C5
and taking the pawn on B7 so what does
Magnus do here you can go Bishop C8 back
and I'm sure you're fine
but otherwise I mean rugby looks kind of
passive and actually maybe you can Tango
Bishop B4
I think Magnus missed Knight C5 the way
he slowed down and he look at his body
language he's missing ideas and it's
really irking him but if you played
Bishop to C8 you just it's kind of a
recognition that something went wrong
instead he gives it the B7 Pawn because
Bishop C8 Rook takes E2 check
uh-huh right so in case white takes
there's here but there's a six though
you can take any two King F1 but the a
pawn could be scary also there are most
like 98 hanging in the position
good point with a knight check this is
looking very tricky and if Yonder Palm
she wants to cut into this lead that
Magnus Carl's Naz he has to play Knight
takes B7 he goes for it I still think
that black should be easily okay here
but Rook takes
oh sorry well Magnus can always lose per
episode straight at the right moment go
Rook B8 although if he does so right
away there might be Bishop B4 and like
all of a sudden it's lost but yeah he
should still be completely fine but he
has to be careful
and he does does go for the e-pawn and
he's thinking after King to F1 but what
is wrong with Rook A2 Knight d8 check
King ah key E8 Knight takes C6 barely G4
by Young I think he rushed at a seafood
C5 gray move by Magnus he won't second
B7 followed by Rook B8 and now there's
no longer Bishop two B4 maybe Jan should
have played like Bishop if I have to set
up the idea but I think now Magnus is
doing great yeah because Madness is just
going to steal a pawn and that Rook on
h8 is trapped what do you do about that
like The Rook is simply stuck in the
corner
I don't see a movie sex it on f8 what
and takes a C5 but Robert it has to be
lost so the a pawn is going to disappear
very soon and you will be down a very
clean exchange well maybe he gets Bishop
b68 now oh what a fine from Magnus
What a fine he's gonna be up a clean
exchange here and this one is gonna I
mean this right now is just a matter of
technique I'm pretty sure this end game
has to be winning he goes at five to
break up the pawns it still requires
some work though to to actually win this
game
yeah perhaps there is a chance here for
Yan I mean I was looking at the eval bar
well now it says he's losing so before
it was all the way down there but look
at this he's gonna go cut this king off
and then bring his own King in
because G5 that gives him a weakness on
on the G5 Square though but I assume
that sooner or later white is going to
lose his Pawn on F3
I feel like Magnus just knows when
positions are winning he he just
protected his Jeep on and he'll bring
his King in like right now and then if
the bishop somehow attacks the pawn
again he'll bring his Rook back to D5
but that's not happening
exactly okay so for the moment John is
hanging on you sit with the bishop here
but I assume that at some moment you're
gonna end and end up in zutong
so how do you ah that's a nice move if
you take then check in King E3
that's sick that's such a nasty way to
win the game which Magnus Carlsen does
and he currently leads by Five Points
Over Yonder Palm G look at Yan's face
that's a man who has been facing off
against Magnus Carlson for hours it's
not fun when you're on the losing end
no certainly not looking like fun here
for young he still had some chances but
he's down five points in match Robert I
don't see him making a comeback here
it's going to be difficult when you're
facing Magnus Carlson who is unhappy
with his play that much has been clear
he's missed things uh they haven't been
there's like huge blunders but they've
been inaccuracies and he strives for
Perfection but when you're playing you
on the palm sheet leading by five points
that should feel as close to his
Perfection as you could possibly hope
for it's a big lead we only have one
time control left 30 minutes of bullet
Benjamin what can janaponsi possibly do
to make it a comeback
I think the first game is going to be
critical if Jana wins the first game
with the with the black pieces he still
has a chance he could get some momentum
win one game after another you know in
bullet you might easily get tilted so
the first game is is critical if you win
someone he has a chance if he loses I
think the match is practically over
I think that he needs to get some energy
he needs to get that break in get
refreshed and while we're speaking of
energy we want to take a moment to shout
out our new partner to the speed Chess
Championship
ag1 ag1 is your daily support of key
Health functions from mental performance
to energy and the immune system it's the
one product that does the work of many
to find out more visit drinkag1.com
chess or use the command ag1 in chat
thank you to ag1 for sponsoring the SCC
we will be right back here in the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
this has been a fun match it's Magnus
Carlson versus John the popsy bullet
coming up after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I've been using it for a long time I
mean if you look up here I actually have
my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got
unjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like this
so they're like how many adjustable
books you got I'm like all of them how
are you accessible is actually I do a
lot for the opening training I do
tactics on here I do calculation I do
in-game I do everything but the database
all my training on here all the time
chessable is the wave this is why I like
to use trustable it's actually helped me
I remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 and bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just
just being honest with you
foreign
chess variants or just looking for
something new join us for the variants
Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions
learn a new variant and compete against
other players for prize money or just
play for fun look for Community Arenas
streamer Arenas and Championship events
six weekly Arena tournaments held every
Thursday will be followed by a
championship event with cash prizes
including a one thousand dollar first
place prize the third and final weekly
Arenas will be streamer Arenas featuring
gifted Subs as prizes
win any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Championship presented by coinbase
Magnus Carlsen may not be in his chair
but he is in the lead in his match
against John the Palm she there you now
see the number one rated player in the
world it has been his summer Benjamin
he's played in five events in recent
months and look at his results he won
two Champions chess tour events he won
the super United grantchester wrapping
in Blitz he won the World Cup second in
the bowl Chess Championship he's been on
absolute Terror
exactly and the only time he did not win
he will stop by Hikaru Nakamura in the
finals of the bullet Chess Championship
but right now he's on his way to a very
smooth victory over Yana ponyashi he's
up five points in the match Yang will
need a miracle come back here Robert
he'll need to do something differently
than he has been because Jan even when
he's been able to string together a
couple good games Magnus is able to just
get right back up and steal a victory so
for Magnus Carlsen a five-point lead
it's hard to imagine him letting this
slip but it's bullet chess Mouse slips
lost on time disconnects they can all go
one player's Direction
and we are off Magnus opens up with a
London system young responding with the
copycat with Bishop five another three
so let's see Queen B6 here by Jan
hitting the opponent B2 which is always
a little bit awkward to defend
right because if a queen B3 black throws
the pawn of the C4 and so Magnus he says
I'm gonna defend by attacking something
else and now his Queen can slide to that
Diagon that goes to B1 the engine didn't
like it but Queen B1 Magnus he chose to
put it on that square
but he still has a very comfortable
position here at the opening against
London
can't complain if you have this in the
black side and now that Bishop Cannon
does sliders the F5 the queen is under
threat but that's why the bishop steps
in between so trades seemed to help
White's cause but B2 is loose here can
you capture it
you can take but why does banking on the
Move Rook fb1 if the queen Mushu can
take the pawn on B7 so let's see if Jana
is going to take he can also of course
continue to improve his position with a
move like Rook ac8
Rook a to C8 always a natural move A4
expansion on the queen side A6 that was
a move that cost yawn in the world
championship match remember the exact
structure like this this was a problem
for him
yeah so now the ideas that engaged into
five white ones go Pawn take C5 and if
you recapture the queen there would have
been B4 Magnus now steps is nine in the
center with 95 and I think slowly but
surely Magnus is gaining the upper hand
here as his pieces are slightly more
active that Queen on A7 it's offside
it's not really helping out in the
position and black shuts it down with C4
so we're gonna have a closed game here
of maneuvering chess but this should be
good for white who controls an important
Pawn break B3 and E4 both of them it's
up to White
that looks so unpleasant why it's going
to recapture your Knights under attack
oh he takes an F5 right away
he just wants to open up the black king
and he brings Knight to F3 this looks
like a French defense with that
backwards E6 spawn
no no this looks terrible you cannot
take on a five he goes B5 but this might
give him even more weaknesses Magnus
goes Knight F3 but look at this property
he's up upon and the D5 Pawn is so weak
yeah missed the rook and see it was
loose so he couldn't recapture on E5 now
suddenly black trying to drop some
counter play over there the A5 Pawn is
gone the C3 Pawn may be next but is the
black king going to survive
I don't know Robert it looks like if
this knight ever lands on a five or
there goes the d-pawn oh and there goes
that's one game yes he gets the Rook
with check he takes the other Rook nice
tactical awareness for Magnus Carlsen
and I don't think janapanji has to draw
here it looks like Rook d8 would win he
resigns Magnus is now up by six
yeah so let's see if maintenance can
come back if sorry Jan can come back
with white piece he plays the Vienna
game all right Magnus goes for his quick
95 move going after Bishop but yeah it
also a very smooth victory for Magnus
and I like that Jan he is mixing it up
with queen of H5 he's saying the E5 Pawn
but Knight to B4 the queen on D1 does an
important job now black gets quick
development I like stealing material and
bullets so Benjamin I think from John's
perspective it's a successful opening
right he's up a pawn here but Magnus is
very easy peace plays Bishop drops back
to f8 and his Bishop on B7 is so active
always putting pressure on the white
King on G1 rookie eight I love that move
he just wants to go Rook 88 maybe Rook
G6 Robert I think I'm bullet this is
really a dream position for black like
all of your moves come so natural yeah
suddenly it's really difficult and he
blundered the H3 Pawn F3 Queen takes H3
thank you very much for the attack and
the material and you can see the
frustration on Jana palmistry's face he
can't believe what's happening here but
nobody can believe the level of chest
that Magnus Carlson tends to show
now he's playing so well and so quickly
look at the clock forward he's up to 58
seconds it's it's incredible that he's
just playing all these moves instantly
and yeah that's just his instinct is on
another level
and F5 kicks the Knight out of there
opening up that Bishop B7 once more the
Knight goes to G5 but I feel like black
just brings the Knight back to D5 F4
threatens to win the piece oh this is
terrible for white
exactly everything is so super loose it
goes net H3 but there's got to be so oh
look at this hitting the bishop in The
Rook that is a sick fine he just gives
up an exchange to win a pinned Knight
the 99 A3 sorry the pawn on G2 is pinned
to the king that is so nasty
yeah and there's nothing you can do here
with why Jana's gonna lose another game
and he's gonna go down seven points
which is unbelievable when Magnus plays
like this there's nobody who can stop
him and we mean nobody he is now going
to be up a minor piece Jan has to throw
in the towel seven point lead for Magus
Carlson
yeah to be fair there is still that guy
hikarnakamura who you know is very much
on par with him with bullet but you know
Magnus is playing out of his mind right
now playing Super quickly finding all of
these tactics in just a blink of an eye
and look at this position there's a
black knight out into White's camp on B4
it's kind of Trapped but it's hard to
attack because C5 there it goes you
defend it if the Knight takes back
the night is now safe but the D6 bonus
week which is why Menace goes Bishop two
F4 Jan has to go either I was gonna say
either E5 or D5 but it goes 98 that
looks a little bit passive and white
goes E5 if you take on E5 the Queens
will be traded and white would take back
on E5 so this looks like kind of a sort
of French defense with the bishop down
there on C8 what do you make of this
position where black just stole upon the
center and Magnus once again he's
surprised and can't believe that he's
blundering things
I like this position before but now uh
Jonas have a problem I don't like what
he did though trading voluntarily in
English B5 he loses a lot of time I
think he should have just gone like 57
but now his Queen is under attack this
rook and swing all the way over to H4
and this looks super unpleasant Robert
H6 he's going Alpha zero style that
Queen has to go to h8 for oh
oh my gosh the king is just getting
mated the Knight D5 route 97 this is so
miserable
this is tough I mean where do you even
go with the queen if they can be two
maybe a rook before the queen has to
leave the diagonal and when you do
there's got to be Queen E4 and white has
to be winning there this looks tough
this looks tough yeah this is your Rook
take on E8 Knight F6 check everything is
hanging there so it goes Knight D6 at
long last is some even material and
white king is much much safer
and look at this Rook before The Rook is
coming up to B6 the spawn on B7 is super
weak Magnus can now just take it he's
gonna take him B7 taking A6 and then all
of a sudden he will have three connected
passengers on the queen side
and look at this Jan just tries to bring
his Rook to the center but he's down
three pawns on the queen side as you
mentioned Bishop C4 another really
precise move trading off the Bishops
there is no hope here for black
you know as king's head is also getting
ripped apart maintenance can just trade
here push the ball of the board Rook B8
now and yeah this is going to be another
good win
this is easy there's no threats from
black The Rook on f8 can be traded off
the board
I don't even know what to recommend
yep resigning that that's the thing I
would recommend here it looks over
he's listening he's listening he heard
and Janda Palmer she if he had any hopes
to win this match in the bullet those
hopes are dashed because Magnus Carlson
is just too darn good
yeah Magnus playing the Philadelphia
defense here young going for a Italian
setup eventually does go D4 and let's
see what Magnus is going to do here
maybe 95 96 but Magnus playing out of
his mind finding all of these moves
super quickly and it's tough it's tough
if you're young like magnus's instincts
are just on another level
and this type of setup Daniel was
talking about the other day from the
black side it's very difficult to prove
an advantage for white those D6 pawn it
looks like a Target but black has the
perfect cocoon to keep it safe and sound
exactly yeah the apology six sometimes
it's a little bit weak but for the
moment that's not an E5 is blocking the
diagonal of the bishop the problem for
black can be though is that you're a
little bit cramped for space so I guess
main is going to go Bishop D7 Rook 88
and Bishop C8 to at least have this room
defending the D6 Pawn yeah black does
have everything together and look at
this queen before move the F4 Pawn the
E4 Pawn both feel a little bit loose and
speaking of loose G3 that looks Loosey
Goosey in front of the white king and
black decides to strike but maybe Jan
has had this worked out
yeah I think Magnus rushed here a little
bit with the most D5 and 94 it feels
like this shoot back first the pawn on
e4 is so weak and yon should be able to
pick it up sooner or later for the
moment yes one was Queen though but this
Pawn is going to be gone or F5 is trying
to make it spicy and the Eva Bar says
that Jan made a mistake here the king is
just so open on each one
right now there's visually three for men
used to block the default and attack the
Knight on G6 Magnus had to move Bishop
takes H3 taking the queen when he was
still defending the The Rook on e4 and
now it looks like Jan has a slight edge
here in the end game
nice move the Rook D6 hitting the bishop
and putting the Rook on defended Square
so D takes C3 will be next and if this
is better for white it's gonna be very
difficult to prove but the white king is
closer to the middle and black has to
start defending those Pawns
okay G4 nice move here by yellamma can
you see a trade now John has to stop his
King but I think it's going to be
difficult to do because whenever your
king steps up Magnus will have a lot of
checks also these pawns over here are
quite loose so you're gonna have to be
very careful here if you're white yeah
Bishop E7 a nice move giving up C3 for
H4 now Bishop D6 check if the King has
to go to H3 it's very far away from
where it needs to be which is D3 to win
that c Pawn so Bishop ooh Bishop F6
wait a second uh-huh she was offering
the shade of Bishops with yawn instead
goes after the A5 Pawn also looks good
what does Spike do here if you take an
A5
which was a little bit off though but
but what does black do
I don't know this actually looks quite
decent for white you're stealing a pawn
and then your b-pawn is free so he runs
with his King
ah the King is trapped for white imagine
if that black king gets all the way into
the position
he's threatening made now and you have
to go G5 but then black is a Perpetual
check and check
what a funny perpetual
Yep this is a draw oh is he gonna do the
he's gonna milk a clock a little bit and
well just for a second and there we have
to draw
and still over 19 minutes remain in the
match John napamsi earns his first half
point in bullet and with an eight point
lead for madness John has to win all the
rest of the games at this stage
yeah it might almost be mathematically
over uh Magnus has a has a hefty Hefty
lead and not that much time left so
let's see how young will try to fight
back but it's looking tough
it is and this position is also looking
nice for white you see black throw pods
for with G5 black probably has a castle
Queen side but the pawn structure is
favorable for white because of those
double Pawns
yeah but at least John has a
double-edged game he goes F4 trying to
break open the king side but Magnus
keeps it close and Strikes in the center
with the move E4 now however you take
you're gonna recapture with the Knight
and then you can follow with the D5 push
so
G4 I like this move by Young
and he's going after the white king but
D takes C6 and does hit B7 we might just
see a bunch of Trades but Benjamin as I
look at this White's Pawn structure is
healthier those double F pawns but maybe
black is in time with the counter play
against the E4 Pawn
yeah and he takes upon queen of Sun by
Magnus though hitting the pawn on C7
which will be Checkmate end upon an F6
but John does have a time to trade be
careful though because now Queen E7 is a
deadly deadly threat so let's see how
he'll deal with it Rook d8 comes to mind
trying to trade off White's rook and go
for a background Checkmate of your own
but maybe there's just a series of
checks after that instead goes for the
E8 Square oh
he had Rook G8 and there would not have
been a good way to sub checkmate oh my
gosh he rushed it it is bullet chest
they're gonna make moves quickly but
Rook G8 would have given Jan a winning
position
on the and right now it looks like
Magnus is firmly in the driver's seat
Rook takes a four everything is defended
rookie two I mean I guess maybe he's
trying to take on B2 but maybe now
Magnus can go for an attack with queen
d8 and Rook Cafe to follow
to turn this around in this manner I
mean Jan he missed his one chance and
suddenly it is oh who could have been in
the offensive but he plays a little
slowly there
Rook F3 still he is defending every
single Pawn on the board he's got these
uh passers Queen D6 now though okay H4
by young I don't think you want to trade
no you definitely do not it's going to
be a great Rook end game for white and
still looks good for white watch out for
Queen F3 check that's why he goes back
to the eighth Rank and white is just
picking up H4 a nice technique for
Magnus
yeah he's slowly but surely maneuvering
his pieces he can actually take the pawn
in case of Queen E6 there's Rook F4 and
you now have three connected passers on
the king side G3 defense everything you
have to be careful though not allow
Queen D5 so let's see how he will deal
with this
it's the only way for oh Queen C5 check
after awkward xc7 just leads to mate so
all of this is a problem there goes a
rook and that's another game for Magnus
can't stop won't stop Magnus Carlsen
wins again and Jana Pomchi he cannot be
having a good time at this stage of the
match
yeah right now it's a nine point lead
for Magnus young going for a reversed
Pierce or modern however you want to
call it Magnus playing a with a G6
here white can hope for a small Edge
because the 96 is restricted but yeah
Magnus is playing great chess right now
where Magnus plays like this it's both a
treat to watch and a nightmare to face
so for yonda palmshi the match started
pretty well for him he was up a point
very early on but then Magnus started
finding his footing and it was all
downhill for there for down to Palm
machine so as we get to the final
stretch of games 15 minutes left in the
match now we just get to watch without
the pressure of the match score because
it is officially in the books Magnus
Carlsen is going to make his way to the
semis
exactly yeah no I think the thing for
John is that magnus's instincts are so
good and that really shines through in a
bullet portion he was hanging with
Magnus in the blitz however I think to
give himself a chance he needs to at
least be even going into the bullet and
perhaps even have a small lead but the
fact that he already went into the
bullet portion with a four or three
point deficit it makes it very tough
yeah I can't even give any advice I
obviously don't know what takes to beat
Magnus Carlson there's pretty much just
one player I should say two because
Maxim vashilagrov who is playing right
after this against nihal sarin he has
beaten Magnus Carlson in the SEC format
but Hikaru and Magnus they're the only
two winners of the speed Chess
Championship they continue to show their
dominance
exactly yes so here we're sitting with
Knight C3 by Jan we see trade now he's
got the double pawns and C5 and Magnus
Magnus slowly but surely out playing him
in this end game now perhaps B6 97 96
and uh yeah like like I said how do you
deal with the Magnus that's on fire
that's just playing out of his mind
playing quickly finding every single
move the only player we can ask is how
to see Cara Nakamura and look at this
rerouting Knight B7 Knight to D6 or A5
the C4 Pawn is loose and if you defend
that with a knight to E3 the bishop go
to H6 to remove the guard and pin that
Knight that Bishop on C1 has not a
single inch in this position no light of
day for it it's a miserable defense for
white
right so maybe you have to sit with a
knight on a through but if you said with
the Knight of A3 it's going to be super
passive and black can prepare a central
push with F5 and yarn going down to
eight seconds I think he's he's given up
well he knows that it's mathematically
impossible for him to win this match
maybe he does want to steal a couple
games against Magnus down the stretch
but Magnus it feels like he doesn't care
what the match score is he wants to win
each and every game and by the way Jan
is playing pretty well to complicate
matters here
can perhaps trade go king of six or it
goes king of six right away but yeah
that's what makes these top players so
good Robert they're super competitive
they they just want every single game
they cannot accept a single loss and
that's why you know we see Magnus and
Hikaru year after year in these finals
and Magnus Scoops up the C3 Pawn as you
said he wants to win even this game and
goes after now the A3 Knight in the C4
Pawn next and suddenly black seems to
have a humongous advantage
black now has three Queen side passers
maybe just B5 or Bishop D4 and now just
push the pawns on the board this has to
be a win for black Robert
for sure too many extra pawns they're
easy to push white has an h-bond but
it's on its starting Square this is no
hope for white in this position and now
the a pawn can push for black as well
all three of them oh that's a free night
that's a free oh
he didn't take it
it's like I don't win your night I want
my three connected on the queen side
yeah that should be good enough
oh this has to be one for Magnus
King goes back and now the F pod is
about to Queen and Knight G3 does the
bishop yep
yeah so black up a piece
as I say bench I don't even know what
more there is to say and Madness is just
crushing it
right and now he's up 10 points it's
starting to look tough for young it's
starting to look tough for young I think
right now his only goal would be not to
lose by a 10 point margin
and it's going to be difficult to do
that because there's still 12 minutes
left in this match which means we're
going to get a number of bullet games
and it's very clear that Magnus Carlson
is far stronger in the quickest of time
controls against Beyond apology but Jan
he deserves credit because he kept this
very competitive in the Blitz and then
Magnus is able to run away with it down
the stretch here in bullet
exactly yeah Magnus playing I would say
Magnus is playing at his level or maybe
even a little bit beyond it yawn however
we talked about this before the match if
he wants to give himself a chance he
cannot lose games unnecessarily but he
did have a few blunters here and there
and yeah as we see then you're just
gonna have a tough day at the office
against Magnus
every day is probably a tough day
against Magnus Carlson and in this
position Magnus stealing the queen side
he took B7 A6 is going to be loose with
that 99 there goes Queen
oh oh my goodness Magnus just forgot a
knight could capture his Queen
and a boat has Gambit in the speed Chess
Championship who would have fought
Robert
not Magnus Carlsen but he is a bad
history of the A6 and C7 squares because
a year ago when he was playing Hikaru
Nakamura I said oh what about Bishop C7
didn't realize that the Knight on A6
could capture that Bishop Magnus played
the move and Icarus stole that piece and
this was C7 to A6 so there's something
about those two squares that are
difficult for Magnus with those enemy
Knights
yeah I saw someone make a tweet that
Magnus the only thing he sometimes
blunders are Night Moves Like if you
look at some of his losses he blondes a
night move like a night fork or or
something of that nature which is quite
interesting and here we see yet again
and he's fortunate that all of his slips
throughout the day losing on time in a
drawn position Mouse slip to lose not
just one but two pawns earlier in the
match and then there to just hang your
queen in a winning position he's so
strong that even after that he's still
up nine points
yeah now he's still dominating this
match he's even better in this game the
rook and C1 is more active than the Roku
B2 and the spawn C4 is a little bit weak
we see Bishop B5 by Young trying to
trade that activation before
and this end game is one where black is
in the driver's seat because that A2
Pawn will be grabbed the Knight on A5 is
in an awkward spot but I guess there's
not too much life to this because the A7
Pawn the C4 Pawn there's a likelihood
that they'll be traded for each other at
some moment
exactly now but you can take an A7
because Knight exporters Knight X4 with
check so wait Magnus all of a sudden in
trouble C5 by the way is a game winning
side or Knight B7
so Magnus blundering a second game in a
row and he plays Rook A4 to protect his
Rook the Knight does cover that there's
no discover check that will win material
right so let's see how Jan is going to
try to win this one it's still looking
very unpleasant for Magnus he's down to
pawn he's in this pin or Discovery but
Rook a six now you just go King here or
here well King C5 he won a knight B7
check so there were some tricks going
after the F7 pawn and will we just see a
repetition I don't think Jan wants that
oh a key C8 Magnus maybe it's striving
for more
right or he thinks that this is a better
move right now he might not be worse
anymore 1964 is a threat C5 Knight C4
attacking the knight in 1996 but you can
just trade the Knight is almost trapped
and then take an E3 or or King C6
and then we just see full on liquidation
it's a king and pawn end game this is
obviously a draw the players know it but
Magnus is just going to make a bunch of
moves to burn some of the match clock
well there are still chances for Magnus
because after this trade if you get the
king to B3 it's winning but can he can
it can uh can he make him run out of
moves on the queen side for on the king
side first
well no because Jan played G4 to freeze
black spawns they just repeat moves the
king's in opposition and a draw is Rich
so it's still a nine point lead for
Magnus Carlson he's crushing it right
now but what is this
I think this is known to be a lost
variation but nobody knows like how to
actually review this you take on G2 you
you uh White has the give of The Rook it
gets a strong attack in return but you
have to know what you're doing here with
white
and the 90s coming to F4 and the G6 it's
clear to the plan but can blackplay Rook
takes H7
and then run the kingdom you can yeah
and look at Magnus he is not liking the
way he's playing because he just saw
Rook takes H7
exactly and we see here the evil bar is
in the middle so it feels like Magnus
did not play in their precise way and
now it's all the way down so actually
this is worked out brilliantly for Jana
ponyachi he played a dubious opening but
a very provocative one he made Magnus
prove it Magnus didn't know how to
punish black and now after Queen takes a
turn I think black's just winning it
should liquidate into an end game that's
a beautiful tactic in Black's favor and
Jana pump she finds it and look at
magnets he kind of gives the face of
yeah good find double exclamation point
and he resigns on the spot so Magnus I
don't think he's enjoying these last
couple games
yeah no I think he for sure would have
lost a win by a 10 point margin but now
Jana's closing it down a little bit he
plays the alakai with Knight to G8
robber what do you make of this opening
he loves doing stuff like that Magnus
has done this in olympiads he's done in
plenty of classical games uh what's it
called the Norwegian lion or rat or I
forget what the name of the opening is
where he puts his Knight on H5 like the
north C variation something to that
effect
exactly yeah so we see Bishop B7 it
looks pretty alright here for black
white is the bishop error but the Nano
C3 is slightly misplaced in on the other
hand black is pretty nice development
and the Bishops for the moment aren't
that effective and I love this maneuver
here by Magnus that I've had E6 I wish I
could put my knight to F6 and back to G8
on my first two moves and get a position
like this I don't know how he does it
but we just saw a bad opening payoff for
Yan and now for Magnus it's the reverse
where his Bat opening or not bad but
questionable it looks pretty good for
black at the stage
exactly this Knight is jumping around
now it has to go back to H2 and Oliver
wait 1965 that's a pawn with Knight F5
check is probably what he's looking for
and there might is there King F6 there
no way
oh he goes for it he he wins King of the
Hill he wins King of the Hill
and then you can end the game yeah
that's done King of the Hill we got this
and but the King on E5 is somehow safe
enough because Queen C3 check there's D4
and the King will Scurry back to F6 and
the F5 Knight actually is hanging after
Queen C3 so what a decision from Magnus
he's getting away with it
yeah king of six and now he's completely
safe 94 do not take us after 364 your
king is in a deadly check but maybe
rookie eight defend the Knight and if he
gets the game to G7 it's just over
Robert
and if he trades on E6 and brings the
king to E7 that also looks very good so
Queen C3 I really like that move because
you take on D4 Queen takes D4 check your
King has to go to G5 and there might be
Queen D2 Queen D4 some kind of draw by
repetition
right so let's see what Magnus is gonna
do this looks like a nice little move by
John I don't see how this king is
getting out of here
I don't either I think I would just swap
Knights and D4 and try to make that draw
if it is indeed a draw
right oh queen bees Robert 1966 D4
Knight takes Rook takes E1 and then you
take the Knight what a find
that is a beautiful variation that the
Knight on E6 it's free for white to take
oh we take it from The Rook but there's
no way it's not E5 it's over there's no
follow-up and Madness wins a brilliant
game Queen B6 there are you kidding me
I'm looking for a draw he finds a way to
get a victory there Magnus Carlsen I
know it hasn't been his absolute best
because of some of the mistakes he's
made but he's played a really great day
of chess
there was a brilliant game and yeah to
be fair he should have already won after
King takes C5 but the engineers finally
got the win through a couple couple
moves later but yeah brilliant stuff
there by Magnus
and I think they're looking at the
overall match clock I'm not sure if Jan
really even wants to continue at this
point but it is a match victory for
Magnus Carlson he's going to move on to
face Wesley so in the speed Chess
Championship semi-finals and Magnus
wasn't perfect right we know that there
are some slim sloppiness there I lost
some time but I see the players they're
communicating and maybe the match is
over with
right do you think Jan has resigned the
match maybe the game was a little bit
too too much and I think you oh wait
they're off yeah but the thing is they
are allowed to uh resign the match if if
they want to but there I think is a
price money cut that you uh sacrifice
because well the fans they want to see
all the games played and you know it's
good just to play at the last couple
bullet games so we see here that these H
pawns are off the board this is the type
of opening you really only see in the
quickest of time patrols but it's fun
for the fans
exactly a year 96 a tricky little move
by Jano Knight xc4 wait there goes upon
Bishop C3 Magnus that's okay he just
sacks the rook and Jan doesn't care
about the Rook either
well he wants to keep his King safe
because in bullet chess King safety is
Paramount and suddenly Magnus who
dropped a Pawn on C3 is throwing his
other pawns up the board I think both
players they really do want this match
to be done let's be honest about it but
for Jan taking a few more points he
won't regret that
no for sure because just to remind
everybody the prize money is split also
proportionally based on the score so
these last couple of games still matter
a little bit for a couple hundred bucks
as we see here John does a pretty fine
position uh with the Rooks on the B and
C false putting maximum impression upon
on C4
yeah it's a position where equal
material but the position is definitely
not even as the C4 Pawn is loose the
dark squares around the white king are
problematic and the light squares too so
Knight G4 played taking control of the
light squares permanently as only black
has a light Square Bishop
yeah black is a nice position here to
policy four is a little bit weak Knight
E4 by Magnus perhaps you want to go to
G3 to put pressure on the bishop and
prepare some H5 push so let's see what
John is going to do maybe like Queen A4
hit the spawn now you can also defend
with 92 but it's of course a little bit
passive it's passive but it does get the
job done and at some point white would
love to double on the e-file but black
forces the trade of Rooks the E7 Pawn
while it's targeted it's hard to bring a
second piece into the attack but your H5
Knight G3 idea you need to keep an eye
on that if you're young to Palm machine
right and then I can also go to E3
putting pressure on the bishop and
defending the Knight the pawn of C4 so I
love this maneuver here by Magnus
looks oh where's oh if Bishop takes
there's rookie a check and check me on H
Madness is going for the kill
right now Knight of five or Knight H5
looks crushing
Oh Daddy takes F5 was better because the
Rook E8 stuff
wait check yeah I have to go King E7 but
that looks deadly you kind of go to yeah
because we're 66.
so where is The Knockout Queen at oh and
if King E8 is their Knight G7 check Rook
takes E6 is coming but what is the
threat exactly Robert can you cannot
think because of rookie won
Queen G7 oh I know this is awesome this
also should do the trick he does deliver
me but rookie 896 would have enough
forcing mate that would have been just
too much to handle
right and now y'all opens up with the
move 1v3 this is officially the last
game of the match the move G4 I've seen
dying play this a couple of times
usually goes like H4 or like C4 and
Knight C3 but we here we see Magnus
taking advantage of the open HR
B3 Cowboy he goes for it and we have a
trait of light Square Bishops I don't
think black could possibly be worse here
healthier Pawn structure King is now
well it had to move but it's safe well
it goes the pawn though yeah I spoke too
soon this is bullet chess after all
exactly yeah upper Pawn here with
maintenance having pretty good peace
play The Rook is pretty active the
knights are nicely positioned and uh but
yeah we see Jan upon upon here and he
can now go E4
yes because after Knight H4 there's Rook
G3 ideas he breaks his second Knight
into the game and black targets the D4
Pawn watch out because the King on C1 is
not the safest King as that pawn would
need to be back on B2 to cover up the
dark squares
right so maybe now move like C5 if you
take the queen and slide in with Queen
A1 track so I think Jan should have
played King B1 to make sure that none of
that ever happens
he simply allows the check the King goes
into D2 and he says no more checks for
you but Queen takes A2 there still looks
like the white king would have been in
danger
and this is so impressive Robert Magnus
is down a palm but he offers a trade of
Queens he realizes that his Rooks are so
active on the HL there's nothing for
white to do here he cannot set his Queen
side majority of motion and black is
slowly but surely going to push up on
the king side
how does he do this he's down upon
a pawn trying to play for more he's got
an active King if you ever push your
queen side pawns as white I think that
the king needs to stay put on D2
otherwise the black king goes to E3 and
that's a problem so wow I just can't
believe what I'm seeing half the time
when Magnus plays end games
yeah oh and Rook H7 he's sacrificing the
Jeep on with one to go Rook C7 and girth
it upon a C2 this is a master class
Robert
or to go on the offensive and we've
already seen him win nice end games two
Rook end games he's just winning a pawn
now
Rook C5 there's no way to defend the
pawn on B5 maybe you have to go like B6
or maybe some okay go C4 he's allowing
up a son though
uh this looks lost you just trade
everything you're equal on the king side
and you're up upon the queen side this
is over
and just go after this A6 Pawn as long
as you don't allow the white king to F2
and like an E3 Checkmate that would be
the only thing to look out for but it's
not gonna happen
right rookie two now King E3 and I think
E4 just wins the win the game rookie two
and then Rook takes E2 and it's two
extra Pawns
clean conversion for Magnus Carlson the
match is officially over and Magnus just
an unbelievable skill set in the end
game to take down yonder Palm G in
another one
exactly he beats on by an 11 Point
margin and scores 20 and a half points a
very impressive display here in the blue
portion and it's the first time in all
nine of his SCC matches that yonder
Pomchi has not reached double digits so
he didn't get to 10 because Magnus
Carlson was not in a giving mood past
the point of a few sloppy instances but
Magnus even after all that he wins 20
and a half to nine enough Benjamin it's
ridiculous
it was an extremely dominant performance
look at the scorecard here Robert he
took a two-point lead going out of the
five plus one portion then he won the
three plus one portion by three points
and finally he dominated in a bullet
he's just too good when Magnus is
informed like this even the best players
in the world they struggle to put up a
fight so Magnus Carlson many great
moments from him I'm sure he's was
shaking his head because he believes he
can always play better that's the
striving for Perfection that these top
players must have in order to push
himself to even higher Heights but
Benjamin many many Great Moments and I
uh think that Magnus has a lot to be
proud of
and I'm sure he played some great chess
uh today where he is going to join soon
for an interview but yeah overall he's
he's played some some great chess
and he played some Savvy moves so we're
delighted to take a look at the Savvy
moves presented by coinbase we will be
reviewing a key move from magnus's games
against Jan and Benjamin you know there
were so many to choose from but I
thought that that Rook takes E3 Pawn to
F4 idea by him that was the icing on the
cake
right so
um
wait sorry which game what's that again
it was that bullet game I don't even
remember what number at this point but
it was the game 20 of the match overall
oh right let me uh look
wait don't worry everybody we'll get it
we're gonna get it we have to go back
into the archives to find it and that's
just how many games they play in the
speeches championship format but that
move Rook takes E3 I think uh we have it
just about ready now to show everybody
The Savvy move of the day and Benjamin
take us away
exactly so here after Knight H3 Magnus
was already in a dominant position with
all of his pieces active but here he
found the move Rook takes E3 sacrificing
The Exchange after Magnus after John
took he is not interested in recapturing
inside he goes for the move F4 attacking
the Knight on H3 and The Rook on E3 and
all of a sudden there's nothing I can do
white is completely lost if you take an
F4 black crew captures with a knight not
only is black material but they're also
threatening a deadly attack on G2 and
that H3 is also a threat so Jan played
the move rookie rookie four but now
Magnus takes the Knight Knight F1 and
now Knight E3 and after takes he takes a
rook and Magnus won a crushing game with
the black pieces and that was your Savvy
move of the day presented by coinbase
and it extended magnus's lead in the
match with seven points and there was no
looking back from there so Magnus
Carlson with some sexy tactics if we
could say so ourselves and we are going
to have Magnus Carlsen joining us for an
interview so chat please ask questions
some of them may be featured and asked
to none other than the top player in the
world Magnus Carlsen so we are gonna
head to a break but when you return it's
an interview with Magnus himself here at
the speeches Championship presented by
coinbase
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Championship presented by coinbase
unfortunately we lost Robert through
some technical issues but we are joined
by a very special guest Magnus you just
beat Jan in a very convincing manner how
do you feel about mesh
um it was
um yeah it was a slug really from
from the first moment
um
I didn't actually know that I was gonna
play it today uh I was until I in the
mid I was in the middle of a 21 course
meal yesterday and then
um like in the evening and then I found
out that I'm gonna play the match and to
be honest I was still so so feeling so
sluggish so
um yeah
um I think like against read it I played
okay probably today I played quite a bit
worse
um it's not only about the moves
um I did miss a lot of tactics but
um you wouldn't believe the things that
I actually missed that didn't show up on
the board so
um yeah it was um
I think not a great day of uh of Chess
um felt like
um Jan really never got going after he
lost that fourth game which was pretty
unnecessary and um
um yeah then it was kind of close but
I never
uh never felt that I was particularly in
danger
um but it never felt like I was playing
well either so it was just
raised to the finish line and
eventually we got there
yeah that fourth game felt critical
indeed that young also could have won
but overall you you did impress us with
your chess and Magnus how do you feel
about facing Wesley so in the semifinals
um
yeah of course
I had
yeah one of the most exciting matches of
um of all time against alireza I was
following most of that
um
he's
generally
um you know very strong but also
he's a bit like Jan that he he plays
well and then
he's really tilty sometimes so that's I
think what he needs to
to sort of avoid to make them
the the much much closer
um and for me I just have to you know
prepare better to be better physically
um because yeah now like I'm relatively
rested but like my brain is my brain is
fried so if I'm in good shape then he's
gonna have to play at his very best too
to make it uh exciting
yeah no we definitely look forward to
that match and uh yeah it would be
awesome if you can play even better
there and uh Magnus who do you face who
do you wish to face in the finals if you
qualify
um
to paraphrase with uh grishek said in an
interview a few years ago
um it doesn't matter uh whom I wish to
play because it's most probably going to
be hikara
so um
for me it's all about rights yeah
performing a bit better in the next
match and then I'm assuming that he'll
be there
if I get that
yeah and it would be awesome to see a
rematch again all right Magnus we're
gonna let you go we're gonna let you uh
rest enjoy your rest of your evening
because we have to get ready for our
next match but we thank you for joining
yeah thank you that's going to be um
awesome
um very evenly matched I think
oh right so yeah it was an honor to have
Magnus here on the show so let's have a
quick look at our bracket we see now
that one semifinal is set up between
Magnus Carlsen and Wesley so so the big
question is who is going to face Hikaru
Nakamura in the other semifinal is it
going to be nihal sarin or Maxim vashay
like RAF we are going to find out very
soon as that one is coming up in just a
bit
all right so we are gonna go on a break
don't go anywhere any anywhere guys
because this uh the other summer final
is coming up very soon between nihal
sarin and Maxine the Sheila Graf I'm
going to be joined by my good friend uh
Diana that's keys so we will see you in
just uh in just a few
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign